two
what up everybody
i can't lie this is definitely me where
my little teeth play ethan bradberry
humongous what
this is written of course by the great
schmoyoho
michael gregory
the great can are the great michael
gregory of shmooyoho today is june 20th
monday
my friends welcome and thank you for
joining us
you know the one thing i miss about
twitch is that we got to listen to all
the music
it's true
should we just do that today instead
just throw out the doc and just listen
to the music
chill
you could
thank you
yeah
you know when we were on twitch there
was we would download it and edit it and
then upload it
it wasn't live on youtube so we had the
opportunity to play all this amazing
music
that we don't anymore and it makes me
sad sometimes when we hear songs like
that thank you to hellofresh
hellofresh delivers fresh quality
produce from the farm to your door in
less than a week
so you can savor summer flavors all
season long
get 16 free meals plus three gifts with
code
h3tv16
at hellofresh.com
h3tv 16. what do we got here is that uh
a surfing turf
uh it would appear so damn
damn damn
damn beans wow
all right thank you hello frosh
welcome guys welcome happy monday
wednesday
it is it's not wednesday
incorrect yeah that's that's that's the
next show
i am very happy to report that you know
this episode that we put lots of love
and effort into it was very well
received and did very good on friday you
guys might have seen our
gangbuster bonanza with oliver tree and
bobby lee
and i'm glad everyone liked it i thought
that was
definitely one of my favorite episodes
we've ever done
and it took a lot of effort to get it
together that that boxing ring to get
that in here
is a whole story in itself
i don't know if i should
yeah
yeah
worth it or not worth it you think
they'll hear of this potentially they
might i don't know they have our address
so
not worth it oh my god let's just say we
had some trouble with the people yeah
let's just suffice to say that and it
was super expensive too by the way
but there you have it it was worth it
all worth it
i'm i'm made of a miraculous recovery by
the way i died or was incapacitated in
the last episode but you know
just a minor concussion actually it
turns out
you got that uh homer simpson skull oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah and how's your
grandma olivia
oh i haven't been able to reach her all
weekend are you serious yeah for real
because she left with oliver yeah oh my
god
uh-oh
yo that's disgusting though i'm sorry
that happened like those cheeks no she
looks good for her age don't get me
wrong i mean she's a beautiful woman but
there's something wrong with that man
and possibly your grandma too
i feel like there's something wrong with
both sides of that relationship
wait if they like get married does that
mean oliver will be olivia's new
grandfather yes
grandpa i don't know grandpa okay yes he
be your step grandpa living
step grandpa
well he better get me a good christmas
gift that's all i'm saying
wow that that was that was incredible
and the thing with bobby lee by the way
pure coincidence we did not plan to have
bobby here
he literally just cruised up
and i'm glad he did because he saved me
from that degenerate freak oliver tree
so anyway
we got a lot to do today lots of to talk
about but quickly you know i love this
shirt so much i can't stop wearing it of
course it's i wore it in last episode
and it's teddyfresh.com
a little showcase this is the shirt
teddyfish.com floral terry polo shirt
damn it feels good it looks good it
looks better on in person than it does
here because the green is being keyed
out so it looks great much more
beautiful in person
daddyfish.com
thank you
[Applause]
all right what's the title of the show
the labrance
no a new low for family channels oh yeah
the lebrance dude you guys know about
them
we'll get to that
just one
that was awesome the lebron family
i like that try it again
the lebron
dude that's kind of interesting
[Laughter]
yeah these guys are they're the
christian the christians are the wildest
people
with love to all the christians in the
audience but like some christians just
take it too far man they take the jesus
thing too far
they'd be like they'd be like i'm going
to heaven because i'm good with jesus
and then do like all this crazy [ __ ]
they they take it too far it's like
there's got to be a limit to jesus is
love yeah there's a little bit too much
of jesus in their eyes
i've heard that been said jesus oh the
crazy jesus christ oh jesus kenneth
copeland has some jesus eyes oh yeah boy
i'm just saying and and there's nothing
wrong with i love all the christians i'm
just saying some people take it way too
[ __ ] far and jesus's love has to have
limits
jesus does that's how you end up with
all these freaking predators in the
church because they're all like yo when
when
get to [ __ ] kids and go to heaven hell
no
no pr no p words in heaven dude
it's a great motto
i'm serious who wants to go to hell oh
my god look at this man
this man i think he looks good he's an
absolute [ __ ] demon
this is the engine
this is like a demon
this is a christian leader man and i'm
just telling you this this man is
he [ __ ] kids and drinks blood i was
watching allegedly in minecraft this one
documentary on netflix about it was
called the f
l d l something some mormon offspring oh
i watched that yeah that that was
dude that guy is such a [ __ ] yeah that
was a really interesting documentary i
liked it it was that guy is there's a a
nice place in hell for him
yeah uh on netflix it's the
what was it uh it's what was the name of
the document series on netflix oh [ __ ] i
forgot
good something good um
check this out what do you guys think do
you see the resemblance this is the
little brant dad
and kenneth copeland do you see i mean
they're like he's getting there with the
jesus eyes
right
yeah i believe it
can you find a picture of young kenneth
copeland because that's what i was just
saying
because he's becoming more and more
corrupted by jesus's love amen the
corrupt the corrupting force of jesus's
love that's the blood of god oh yeah the
documentary was called keep sweet pray
and obey yeah a really good documentary
about
some psycho mormon cult where basically
the leader
you know [ __ ] all the women which is
every every cult basically comes down to
one dude just trying to [ __ ] everybody
yeah yeah dude they look they look
similar bro
he looks like he could be his son
do you see it
i do see it can it
i absolutely do see it so there you go
yeah what are we going to do what are we
going to do
um
let's just do it i guess i'm already in
it and then we can go back to the top of
the show so the lebran family
yeah they're the thank yous
they're
so
funny um
they're famous for
among other things click-baiting their
child having cancer
child didn't have cancer
and they made it look like they actually
click-baited their child who they are
already exploiting for views
that
i don't remember was a boy or girl that
i think a girl she had cancer
i mean what the [ __ ]
dude you know and i've talked about so
many times that i just have a problem
with family channels at face value
because
it's just exploitative and there's no
laws to protect the kids you know in
traditional media you have lots of child
protection
laws so anyway here here's what they're
in
and uh
controversy over now lebrant family uses
their son's seizure for clout
nice
yeah i i can't i can't show this too
many times but check this out
we blurred their faces by the way
she got cancer she got diagnosed with
cancer documentary now what does this
thumbnail tell you
this girl has cancer
this poor little girl that's cancer nope
they're all fine
[ __ ] elbro it's one pretty wild
also how do you how do you come like
jesus can't be happy about that no
i'm just saying
jesus is not a fan of that title bro
just saying
bad form
i i want to i need to make a church
that's like
jesus's limited love jesus is love with
limits you know [ __ ] all no
we need limits on this [ __ ]
we need we need a priest to say not you
they say you you you not you get the
[ __ ] out
damn
uh so anyway it was later revealed that
zealand had suffered a
febrile seizure
the seizures are usually temporary and
do not cause any permanent damage to the
child's nervous system well that's good
the leblanc the labrance shared these
photos on both instagram and youtube
so he has a benign seizure thing yeah
it's not really that well i mean the way
he described it in his 25 minute video
about it did sound pretty intense and
scary sure yeah i'd be terrified yeah we
gotta hype it up for the views yeah i
would i would be i would be so scared if
one of my sons started seizuring yeah
so let's see
update on my son's seizure now we should
pull up the thumbnail first so people
can really appreciate
um what we're dealing with oh man they
they really got a lot of views too
comments off yeah
can you are you pulling this thing now
yeah thank you
celine had a seizure on june 1st he is
doing well and appears to have fully
recovered thank you all
for your encouragement and prayer oh
i have the uh
uh dislikes
oh yeah pull that up on or whatever
uh
it's still positive yeah it's not bad
but that's 53 000 and it makes you
wonder if they were visible it'd
probably be even more right
yeah yeah well according to youtube
that's their whole theory right
discourage people from the whole thing
is so weird they can still see it that's
what's so funny you can see the like
ratio on the back end yeah it doesn't
hide it from the creator which is like
they're still gonna see it right and it
takes two seconds to install a plug-in
to
show it again so
yeah it's odd here's the thumbnail
check it out check it out check it out
y'all
check it out
update on our son seizure
poor baby i actually feel bad for him
yeah interestingly the electrodes were
just on the wall and they just put them
on his back for the thumbnail
[Laughter]
more dramatic
all right let's see what these goons
have to say about it
praise god we live right next to a fire
praise god
our neighbor is the fire station that's
literally our next our neighbor is a
fire station so
he but the paramedics showed up about
two minutes after i was doing cpr and
after two they were really fast after
two minutes of me doing cpr before they
got there he had started to breathe
again
um and and it was like instantaneous of
just like the color that came in his
face and like the room do we know if
this video has ads
uh it says in the very beginning of the
video it says that all well let me see
what it says actually it's gonna be
clear something about the money being
donated or something like that okay
that's good that's positive
although i doubt youtube would monetize
this yeah i'll add revenue made off this
video will be directly donated to local
organizations help in childhood seizures
okay like that
believe that
he's not dead yeah we all felt because
we really thought he was dead and again
we're not
i wasn't like checking a pulse without
anything anything it was just total
panic of the cpr and little by little we
it was like a small breath and then like
a small breath like he was struggling to
breathe really hard so we had no idea
the paramedics were shin they checked
his vitals um they started pricking he's
breathing better they started pricking
him and doing like
blood stuff yeah i mean they started
doing the ambulance shows up immediately
right after the paramedics do and um
you load up in the hospital with him at
this one we have no idea if it's gonna
happen again um if it if it was even a
seizure if you know we have no idea all
we know is
what do we got here
first date
do not try to give mouth-to-mouth
like cpr usually start people start
breathing again on their own after a
seizure
when he said that i
was just like that
something in my brain was like i feel
like i've heard you're not supposed to
do that with seizure and
the cdc website saying so so i i guess
it's a little odd that like you thought
your son was gonna die and i mean boy
that that
i just i can't imagine going through
that but it's just incredible to me that
like you hear those moments he start you
know he started taking pictures for his
youtube channel that's so crazy
his first thought was like or maybe his
second thought was like
we gotta monetize this [ __ ] terrible
terrible like this photo here we thought
this is that moment for us yeah um
praise god and then i thought i better
take a photo of this so for you the dope
ass youtube
[ __ ] uh
the paramedics showed up about two
minutes after i was doing cpr and after
two they were really bro what the [ __ ]
that's a really intense photo though
yeah
damn i feel horrible for that that poor
baby i mean he looks to be about
theodore's age yeah
still got a diaper how old is that baby
he is let me find out
is it a competition well i just want to
criticize their parenting if i can
as a as a as
of a father of a similar age one years
old how much one year that baby's one
year oh he's going you're turning two
years in nine days okay
so that's okay yeah that's fine
um
yes so clearly he was like yo my son's
about to die hold up
the paramedics
are
treating your son
and imagine as a paramedic looking up
and the dad is there taking photos like
what like this is so bizarre it's just
so [ __ ] bizarre what was the the
disease that we made up is it vlog itis
yeah
yeah this is terminal vlog is right
there
i mean damn this is just crazy like no
so and there's no justifiable reason for
taking this photo like this there's no
this isn't there's no reason to save
this photo if you're not a vlogger right
like as a parent you would never stop
and take this photo
never never right it just makes no sense
there's no reason for it
yeah that's crazy dude
what the [ __ ]
and then they had the videos pretty much
them explain the seizure i don't know if
you want to watch much more of it but
they kind of drag it out but they have a
conjoint post on instagram as well you
know you can share posts now between two
pages okay good yeah between what
between the father and the
mother there was two minutes to be doing
cpr before they got there he had started
to breathe a little coordination there
with their babies with medical issues
milking new babies teacher just dropped
let's let's go
how do we know that they didn't cause
procedure i'm just saying because they
were they're ready
you know
when they induced it intentionally i
don't know just saying
um
they sure were ready to capture the
moment it was like insane
the color that came in his face and like
the relief that like he's not dead yeah
we all felt because we really thought he
was dead and again we're not
the way he says that is like so
emotionless
i really thought he was dead
i mean i can't imagine a worst
sentence to utter
if one of my kids i thought was dead i
mean that's like life crushing soul
crushing
and he he really glossed right over that
didn't he
yeah
how long after uh this incident was this
video made that's a good question this
is june 5th
he had a seizure on june 1st it says
four days well
had a
few days to process i guess perhaps
anything it was just total panic of the
cpr and little by little we it was like
a small breath and then like a small
breath like he was struggling to breathe
really hard so we had no idea
the paramedics were shin they checked
his vitals um they started pricking he's
breathing better
yeah and then again this photo is the
same thing like
no one would ever take this photo
a regular parent you know what i mean
documenting it in real time yeah there's
there's no justifiable reason imagine
the the paramedics they're putting you
in the ambulance
everybody's stressed and panicking
daddy's like hold on
it's like don't hold on hold on hold on
hold that if it's nuts
don't pull away it don't pull away hold
on hold on one second one second
did you turn a little to the left can
you can you whoa whoa whoa guys can you
come out of that ambulance for a second
i didn't i missed that shot of you guys
going silly one
i mean there's no justifiable reason for
this photo
period get a thumbnail these are all
some potential thumbnails that's true
that's that is true
that is true for sure
pricking him and doing like
and not ignoring the like uh ethical
problem of even putting a young child in
a video who can't consent or understand
the implications on his whole life of
being in these videos
but to put him having a seizure and then
[ __ ] putting him in the thumbnail is
nuts bro it's nuts what stuff yeah i
mean they started doing the ambulance
shows up immediately right after again
what the [ __ ] bro she she she she's just
they're taking photos okay i just
thought about it these are all shot in
landscape mode so legit was he thinking
thumbnail because you oh interesting
thing if you're just whatever for
whatever reason so does that mean he had
to open the camera and then click a few
things to get the right setting uh no
you just wanted to die
oh okay okay okay holding his phone like
this bro that's nuts so his child is
dying
okay and then his wife's getting in the
ambulance
[Laughter]
hold on guys
and then mom is like crying with their
dead baby in the in the ambulance the
paramedics sitting there
hey guys look man this is chris oh my
god i hope he's okay
is it possible that he's recording and
these are just screenshots that would be
even worse they're pretty crisp i don't
think so yeah i don't think so if he was
recording that would be gangbusters he
busted out the 5d for this telephoto
lens
good shot
dslr
whoa dude this photo is crazy why did
you take this photo
this is a photo that should not exist
right
oh my god
dude you're photographing this right now
that's so insane that you're thinking
about your youtube channel right now
it's also like
why would you want to relive this moment
again like it's such a traumatic thing
memories there's there's no reason for
this photo to exist also you can see the
paramedics glove here so he's just
peeping over the shoulder of the
paramedic right here in action taking a
photo that's because he's right behind
him loki is kind of rude to that
paramedic to photobomb him like that get
the [ __ ] excuse me excuse me
probably like why don't you go lay down
on the gurney and hold him you know
give me a thumbs up guys
this is
crazy baby
what did the paramedics do
and um
you load up in the hospital with him at
this one we have no idea if it's gonna
happen again um if it if it was even a
seizure yeah if you know we have we have
no idea all right so my question let me
go back
so this photo so they're in the hospital
and i get this one but if they're in the
hospital the kids recovered
do you think she's looking sad on
purpose let's be real here
um
i won't go that far
i i don't i think they care about their
kids i don't think they're that simple
no i think they care about their kids
but they obviously care about youtube
thumbnails too and this is was the
thumbnail
yeah really sad they he he cares he
he cares about youtube just a little bit
less than his child right yeah he
attended to his child and then he took
the photo right i agree that the the
proportion of care is definitely out of
whack here a little bit but i i don't i
don't think he's
that s sociopathic
so would you take this photo i mean it's
a little more justifiable because it's
not a crisis but still a little sus
yeah
i think that's well said
yeah it's still a little sus
to even take this one
what we know is he's alive
this is [ __ ] up dude
this is just [ __ ] up dude stop with
this [ __ ]
this shouldn't be on youtube you've
demon
this child does not consent or
understand the implications of what
you're doing
and he's on the way to the hospital
civil war so i get in the ambulance with
them and we go to the hospital i follow
right behind them in the car my family
stays behind with
oh oh and really was at dance really
important thank god because i feel like
i really
has the anxiety of cole where she were
to have seen that like her life would
just completely change
yeah but can i just point out if you go
back a little bit to that last photo of
the child sitting in the bed yeah that
looks like not i'm sorry after this one
yeah this one looks like it was in
portrait because this one the child's
okay so obviously not good for click
bait
so this is a real one i'm just saying
it's
the weirdest thing very weird it's
interesting
he took the other ones with that
thumbnail in mind right yeah
that's crazy dude that's crazy dude
that is [ __ ] up
so that is that why everyone's mad just
the the photo
yeah yeah
people are freaking out on twitter
so the little branch shared these photos
on youtube and instagram and then here
is the
the cross posts they did yeah
love that for them
whoa
no no wonder they're doing it 1.3
million likes praise god god is great
praise jesus
no [ __ ] wonder he snapped these sweet
ass photos
he clout getting clouded the [ __ ] up
i ain't getting a 1.3 million likes i
need that clout
damn well maybe you should put your kid
in a dark room with a bunch of strobe
lights yeah i wouldn't even joke about
like
about having something like that it's
way too scary
yo dude okay so here we have the full
no
this is this what do you think about
this this is different this is for the
full scene
the other one was cropped but i think
it's a separate photo it's a separate
photo because she was her eyes were
looking at the camera wait are you sure
i'm absolutely positive pull up the pull
up the no the the medic was sitting down
on the other one too yo he snapped a
bunch this dude
but in different orientations it looks
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah so he did one like
this and then he put it sideways for the
thumbnail
he's like an old school uh photographer
and he's got like three cameras around
his neck and he's you know so at this
point in his story he doesn't know if
his son's gonna live or die
and he's snapping [ __ ] multiple
photos
up sideways
[Applause]
what a demon bro
this actually makes me sick
that poor baby
savannah was supposed to go to be
induced last night at midnight wait they
have another baby yeah they had another
baby named sunday
sunday sunday god's day god's day
how many kids do they have now
uh let's see four or four four or five
yeah they know
the having that kid is a total write-off
for them it's business baby
it's just that's just good business
it's just economical oh yeah
oh yeah
savannah was supposed to be induced god
had other plans
what was god's plan to give your son a
seizure that's not a good plan
it's all part of the plan
i don't like that plan that maybe if i
could ask some questions at this point
there's some revisions yeah everybody's
got their little plans
our z had a rough seizure just hours
before we were supposed to go in we
think it was caused by a spiked fever
what your poor son had a high fever oh
my god enough to give him a seizure what
the [ __ ] going on
he stopped breathing for a while and
went lifeless
dude
sorry but i can't i couldn't describe my
sons as lifeless i think that would
that would tear my heart out doesn't
that seem like a callous word am i being
over the analytical
ethan you're not thinking seo
lifeless
while i was performing cpr on him until
the paramedics show up he slowly came to
and appears to have fully recovered
after spending a few hours in the
hospital plea pre please pray for this
boy
please pray for my wife and our new baby
girl we can't wait to meet because god
please pray hard because god is trying
to kill my son yes uh jocelyn actually
donated five dollars and said one like
equals one prayer one like one prayer
guys
guys one dollar equals one prayer keep
those donations coming
new subs are five prayers okay
gifted memberships are ten yeah lots of
prayers going up here today wow who
wants me to take their money
i love that tai lopez sound by so much
who wants to lose some money today
i just can't imagine the context of that
one let's not talk about making money
okay
good point my wife is the strongest
person i know and there's nobody i'd
rather share these good and terrible
moments with
[ __ ]
there's nobody i'd rather share these
terrible moments with with the [ __ ] and
good because well these are these these
were somewhat good because paul asked
clickbait
i wonder if he was thinking of the
caption as he was taking the photos he's
like man what can i write
so they did a cross post do their photos
usually get this many likes oh they
damn their instagram is popping off what
the [ __ ]
hold on somebody in the chat has really
got me y'all judging them for having so
many kids but at this rate they need
spares they
need what
spares
oh right they need backups they need
bench warmers
they can't get slacking without enough
kids man what happens you know
if one of them dies in a seizure they
gotta sub someone in
their new baby is this [ __ ] took
a picture of his girl sleeping and put
it on instagram
that's weird that's weird because she
she has her own instagram that's kind of
[ __ ] up that he kind of stole content
from me oh the girl has an instagram
yeah these people are sick they know
what they're doing so the baby
whose name is sunday savannah lebron has
an instagram oh
that actually makes me noxious and there
was someone who there's someone who did
a youtube video analysis somehow
there's like third-party stuff that can
analyze the demographics and the people
this is gonna make you wanna vomit but
the people that follow these accounts of
little girls
have like 70 men
that is very scary this is sick
but you know they know what they're
doing is [ __ ] up there's no way
they don't know it
no matter how big you get i always see
you as the little three-year-old girl
that changed my life
we were both kids when we met
i owe a lot of growing up to you thanks
for being so patient with me through the
years
as i've imperfectly tried to figure out
bro whatever but what is this photo doug
it seems like a photo you send someone
as a threat
the reaching out is really cryptic
dude what are you doing you are so
messed up it's me
dude you're seriously the you are you
need to reanal you need to like
rethink everything
why did you unmatch me
that's just crazy to me
so yeah there's the lebron family oh we
have some good twitter reactions let's
take a look
you know twitter's gonna come hard for
these two
let's see i swear the lebron family just
have kids so they can have them make
money on social media well that's
obvious
can you send me the kids social media i
want to look at all that yeah it's in
the dock it's right under that
um right here
sunday already has an instagram that's
the newborn baby
1.5 million followers already so i guess
it's a joint between her and her sister
bro this makes me want to [ __ ] vomit
and imagine it's 70 min
i mean do the math on that
i'm sorry but who's liking this stuff
it's [ __ ] and demented
i wonder do they do sponsored posts with
their babies
that's what i'm wondering you know
interesting let me take a look
all four of the kids have their own
instagram they made them like the second
they were born yeah this kid was just
born they didn't yeah
they didn't
miss a second
how did this must be a miserable way to
live your life i mean this is really sad
like do they even ever have a genuine
moment with their kids
it's really sad
i can't wait for these kids to be a
little bit older where they can actually
talk about how [ __ ] up their lives
were when they're like 18 plus yeah
exactly didn't get a dime from their
parents by the way
oh yeah this is the guy that made that
pro-life documentary
yeah just because you don't believe in
import you clearly don't believe in
abortion
die over here the lighting's better
that's kind of true though isn't it
that's kind of true
so all the kids have a social media
somebody in the chat said
even the semen in his [ __ ] has an
instagram
god jesus
that every every potential life spanx is
semen tastes good
um chocolate that's all one today
they're cracking me up the brant family
is sick is sick
your child needs to be resuscitated and
seizures and you immediately pull out
your camera phone and upload an
instagram post not a few hours later oh
that's interesting
he uploaded that immediately huh
let's see wait was that june 1st that
upload let me check right now stop
exploring your children babies give them
medical privacy uh dude yeah that's
their whole livelihood is exposing their
as exploiting their children it was june
2nd
so it's the next day
if what he said is right because maybe
i i don't know if that's he made have
said it was june 1st
i don't know that's a big accusation
i'm highly concerned that the lebran
family posted a photo of their child in
an ambulance after having a seizure
disgusting of course it's very sad and
scary situation but my mind would be
making sure the child is okay not
snapping a photo for social media well
that's why you'll never succeed in this
business
because you don't have what it takes
they really posted pictures of their
baby post seizure man the lebron family
gotta go i'm dead ass they ain't going
anywhere man that post got 1.5 million
likes so who are you
i'm okay with cola brandt and their
vlogs to make money but do not shove a
camera in your child's face
if said child is in the hospital after
having a seizure it's not right
the lebrand family have dark energy
he sees their baby have a seizure and
things go and thinks to themselves i
better shove a camera in the face yet
totally
there you have it that's the drama
something up guys
oh we're just uh loves having some
issues doing some cpr okay okay
okay
el yara
gators in arizona
star garden dog garnet
[Music]
anyone here from arizona
oh yeah
well if his if his um
tv is dead maybe we could just get a
repeating dan you look really sad real
quick yeah yeah good idea yeah
all right let me get one this way for
social no no no no no no no but wipe
your like you're wiping your tears away
dan
yeah yeah
very good
good good
love dies again the man he can't he
can't stay alive
yeah what the hell that's the second
time you've died god damn rascal
so
there you have it
family
um
the lebron family ladies and gentlemen
yeah and again they made this huge
documentary that was really
controversial
when the supreme court was like uh we're
gonna
get rid of roe versus wade
and they're like yo dude oh yeah they
said the abortion is more deadly than
the holocaust they compared to the
holocaust being like if you think the
holocaust is bad there's like millions
of women having abortions every year
love that for them
their views are kind of really good
though so
good luck guys with that i think they
ain't going anywhere
it's crazy views like 2 million per
video
so who the [ __ ] watching this though
you know i was surprised when i was
going through instagram how many people
from back home from where i'm from
dearborn how many conservative like
muslim
families are liking their stuff it's so
wild to me whoa yeah
whoa
that's odd
so here she has oh evelyn rose has her
own channel just i'm seeing what else
they're up to
let's see
very soon you go to hell and then what
i'm saying cola brandt has his own
channel and of course his has the least
nobody gives a [ __ ] about him right it's
all about the kids and that kind of goes
to show you this has by far the least
amount of views
and he's trying really hard too look at
this he's trying to be mr beast i gave
400 000 pennies to my 400 000
subscribers
yeah thanks a lot dude thanks bro
my troubles are over
i'm surprised hasn't isn't that uh
popular because he was famous on vine
before i think oh no wonder he's so
demented yeah he was a he was famous
online he was on the amazing race with
his mom too right oh so he's been
chasing clout his whole life yeah the
kids are just a means to an end
yep found his niche
but i survived 100 dangerous movie myths
in real life do you see how hard he's
trying nobody gives a [ __ ] about you
dude it's all about your kids
i hate to say it
he's trying to be mr beast it's
embarrassing bro
yeah look at here's another mr beast
31 minutes in last person to leave the
straitjacket wins
you can put your kids in a straitjacket
now
yeah this dude's [ __ ] in the head
i'm telling you man christianity you
can't go in too deep man
just a little bit of christianity is
good but too much [ __ ] with your head
man
telling you
i can't do that
yeah you're in too deep i get it
i believe it
it's like spice christianity is like
spice a little bit
but too much spice you become you go too
deep like
yeah you're talking about the spice from
dude i don't know yeah i was trying it's
gonna turn into a
navigator he's gonna turn into like a
yeah it's kind of dope actually the
navigators yeah
so i don't know
with any religion same extremism
too much
too much yeah but christians scare me
the most
those [ __ ] are wild as hell
um
marianne donated 20 bucks and said
change the title of the episode to love
dies on air rip love
what we could call it follow up to love
seizure
love has a seizure on air
that'd be kind of crazy huh yeah i mean
kind of great love are you okay with us
clickbaiting your death christian scary
of course
thanks bro i just i can't i can come i
can consent unlike the kids yeah that
that was a loyalty test we would do that
too
what the fridge
that's love see we legit put my head in
the thumbnail i mean the hospital once
this click bait and then we cramped down
my head and put your head on my body
what the heck
here's here's a call back to cole
here he is in his vine days dem white
boys
twerk team
nice
damn white boys holla at y'all boy them
white boys he's not a certified white
boy though
you are definitely
so [ __ ] white
them white boys gives me bad vibes
though
yeah yeah
anytime someone's proud of their
whiteness is a bad vibe trust me
nothing ever good comes from that i am
of course
a white supremacist
literally such a red flag just be like
yo i'm what i'm proud of being white
nope
you're [ __ ] i guarantee that person has
[ __ ] up ideas about a lot of other
[ __ ]
i'm proud of being white is the tip of
the iceberg man
damn white boy roster
bigger bigger
chat tonight
a white boy summer
feel the breeze brother
yo that's a pretty good segue
we have a chat adjacent uh video at the
top of the doctor
we have a chinese
grab the camera my son is having a
seizure man
[Laughter]
tom hanks momentary loses his nice guy
persona oh yeah i saw this pretty funny
the check came out
you know if you
if you watch look at this video closely
the person he flipped out at didn't
actually do anything and that that's
kind of crazy
it feels so bad for that kid yeah that
kid didn't do anything like
it seems like she just tripped on
on accident i i don't even know if she
hit someone but watch his wife
so watch his wife
there was no one in front of her there
was nobody in front of her when she
slipped
no the guy she gets pushed from the back
yeah you think so
she stops and i think that person wasn't
paying attention and just bumps into her
so what's happening here
because someone yeah you think someone
kicked the back of her foot or something
yeah like wow her back yeah you can see
it
right there
what are you doing bro what an idiot but
anyway this kid in front didn't do [ __ ]
and he gets tom cruise draft so it's the
blue shirt guy that actually shoved her
i think so i think thanks he said tom
cruise dominic
i
go deep into this the blue shirt guy
pushes their security guard or something
is that right so he caused trouble
there's a security guard
exactly behind tom hanks
that's
dude you got to upgrade your security
tommy
anyway let's watch
this
knock it over my wife yeah they're
bugging sorry to talk about that
[Laughter]
sorry this oh no that's like a super
villain origin moment
this guy just got bitched out by [ __ ]
tom hanks and he looks dead inside man
ripped to this kid oh
that shot is amazing
sometimes that check come out
life was like a box of chocolates
sometimes the cheddar come out and uh
[Laughter]
um there that is
by the way we have a we have a an
interest in caller at two right uh yeah
um i should set it up or do we should do
thank our sponsor and then sponsors and
then you can set it up and while you're
doing that we will uh get them on the
line yeah so we have a um
here here is a
just for your viewing pleasure tom hanks
plus chetana
his head's a bit large
for his body
yeah scary knock it over my wife
sorry about that tom
so anyway um
yeah this the caller is calling in at
two someone i've been trying to get for
a minute
this is a very interesting guy
some of you may know him but i'm going
to introduce him to you guys before he
gets on kart narc the kart narc is
calling in folks
this is a guy that roams parking lots of
grocery stores
and other stores
and [ __ ] with people that don't bring
their carts back
it's an interesting niche but he really
gets in there
uh which you guys will see
first we have one sponsor i need to
thank honey
do you know and love let me tell you
about honey
they sponsored today's episode it's the
easy way to save when shopping on your
iphone or computer
i love honey it saves me so much money
my god look at this that's bro how much
money is 400 100 bucks
and that's just the thing you know
you're just casually shopping
and this works for almost every website
on the internet every major one
and when you're checking out
it just knows all the coupon codes in
the world and it automatically applies
it it's so easy
there's no like
catch it's seriously just a plug-in it
takes two clicks think about it dude
um
you know you don't have to worry about
having the best promo code ever again
there it is
thanks to honey manual searching for
coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one it finds to your
car
so imagine you're shopping at one of
your favorite sites and when you check
out the honey button appears and all you
have to do is click apply coupon but a
few seconds is honey searches for
coupons you can find for that site if
honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the price drop baby
this would must be a couch or something
hila got
the crazy one about this is that like
we didn't even know there was a code out
there or we tried looking and it's like
oh [ __ ] we just saved 400 bucks
five bucks 180 bucks
12 bucks you know
it's nuts
oh
yeah i mean clothing food furniture
so much stuff
also this is interesting honey doesn't
just work on desktop it also works on
your iphone now just activate it on
safari on your phone and save on the go
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show
i use honey and i love honey get honey
for free at jointhoney.com h3tv that's
joinhoney.com
h3tv thank you thank you peace and love
peace and love
um
so
oh cam got we got an update cam yeah
that's better that looks
better now he looks like hassan
more accurate
back the [ __ ] off
so let me introduce you to the kart
knock before we have him call in you
guys are going to love this guy i think
uh
let's pull up one of his videos
i'm a fat a-hole it's called
is it about me
you're this close to being on the ground
oh yeah this is a great one
he just walks around with like a police
spam on his chest you know
[Music]
leaving the card there actually makes it
harder for him to open his own door and
he's still doing it all right
slide them up
one good one
[Music]
sir sir you got your car right here
what's interesting he does it by himself
he's just out there [ __ ] right there
they go back where they go
there's one over there see where that
guy's came from or over there where i
just came from over there i just came
from one i'll show you where it
is arcs
looks great it's pretty cheap like
you're even blocking your own door from
opening you understand that i could
block someone else's door from opening
right
no no we're a highly trained seeker
that's not our that's not our siren by
the way that's an ambulance uh we're
hiring a highly trained organization
of narcs
uh oh i wait for this ambulance
if you don't mind
quality siren uh more in the
common usage of it like knocking someone
out snitching on them oh okay not
narcotics like
essentially yeah so what we do that's
great
so we show people throughout their ways
and like that gentleman
i could
four this morning uh-huh i've been
working all the non-stop i think they
paid for a guy to do this ah see ninety
percent of the time i put it back 99 but
you're very tired right now and that's
causing an error in your judgment lazy
bones
no sorry let me explain here i got these
so this is when he turns it up if they
don't put the card back he puts a magnet
on their car and then they really
[ __ ] lose it so you can call that
first thing about it
what's going on what are you doing sir
why are you approaching me
why am i approaching you yes
this is yours take it back no it's got
it's got our number for you it's present
for you
to teach you how to have to be a lazy
boss take it back that's right dude his
car is like open with the keys in here
people are so domestic
i'm a nice guy sir no you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] luckily i have good blocking
skills i have blocked your attack you're
a human [ __ ] i'm a narc i'm
explaining i don't give a [ __ ] what you
are yeah you do because you're running
out of me trying to throw stuff at me so
clearly i don't care what i care about
is you i have rights leave me alone yeah
i know and what i'm saying leave me
alone i'm having a private a small leave
me alone i'm trying to have a polite
conversation no i don't want to polite
leave sir
i'm planning to come see she's over here
let's just do a temp check here like do
you feel bad for the
the car the guy who's been knocked on
i mean he's obviously over the top
it's complicated
hell no bro you don't feel bad for him
[ __ ] no
he didn't put this card back dude
since discovering this channel i've
always i've started always putting my
cart back yeah you don't want to get
caught slipping out of the car i i
remember when i was a kid and some guy
came up to my mom and did this and my
mom [ __ ] unleashed on him like before
this she's yeah she went straight hood
on him somebody called your mom out yeah
she's like [ __ ] you don't know
what neighborhood i'm from who the [ __ ]
you talking about she's like i got the
neighborhood yes yes
and i was like freaking out i'm like mom
please shitty bail yeah he battled he
built i'd like to see the card mark
versus your mom
usually i don't feel bad for them but i
feel like this guy's on the verge of of
like
what's that old movie with uh
oh god we're
i'm sure you know what dan he's go it's
his daughter's birthday and he gets
stuck in traffic and he just loses his
mind and starts killing people he's got
the snow globe oh oh um
falling down falling down
feel like he's like
he's about to do a falling down
his origin story serial killer origin
story right here
by the way watch that movie it's all
crazy falling down [ __ ] yourself the
reason they had the car corral which
we're at by
where you put the carts in i
mean it makes sense i guess it's a
corral i think he's just thought about
it more than most yeah i just thought
just kind of i didn't know it was called
a car corral it just blew my mind i
guess
he is uh he's standing by by the way so
anytime you're right so i just wanna
yeah uh his card
over there you could have put it in
there well sir then you would have
learned you're this close to being on
the ground why i'm i'm not on the other
hand
yeah he's so sad right now he just want
he's so sad but the thing is he can just
go to his car and leave like he keeps
getting baited but he's so sad right now
number one number two you know what and
he's it's probably it's just so
confusing like what why am i in this
situation a [ __ ] cart
it's just nuts but you know because i'm
a [ __ ] fat [ __ ] no sir because i
know what it is because i'm highly
trained and running i we train for this
because we like sometimes people get out
you know what don't get the managers
why look now don't get him what for
because you're bugging me i'm not
bugging you let's go sorry i want to go
i don't want to go there i want to have
a polite conversation i don't want a
polite conversation okay that's all i
know you don't have to you don't have to
you don't have to leave me alone he
didn't take his cart back he's being
very antsy about it i don't know why
he's trying to keep like because you're
abusing me how was your abuse sister i'm
having a polite game
i mean 15 minutes of this man's torture
but but he's actually his tick tocks are
a little more punchy you know
but he's been doing this for a minute
here let's watch another one
just want you guys to capture
all the greatness that is the carton arc
before we talk to the legend himself
yeah this one's only a minute 30.
so he he sounds his own sirens what
you're going to do
what you're going to do when we knock on
you oh your wind's blowing the cart
right into your own car actually sir
look at that this car actually hit his
own car i'll be it very lightly wait
hold on what's in his hand there
i want to know what kart narc is
equipped with
what kind of weaponry he's got look at
that
fantastic
grease removal what are you doing so i
from what i've seen is sometimes he'll
spray that on the car to put the magnet
on
oh
what a [ __ ] clean contact oh my
goodness dude this guy's next level
wow this car actually hit his own car
i'll beat it very lightly
part me sir
you're literally demonstrating the
problem with leaving your card out when
the cart returns right there and right
there
so it's our car dark's here hello
it seems he's not
let the cart out there's someone in the
car that was going on
yeah okay you left your card out
you put your card out like a big old
lazy bones
and the lazy bones it's like so benign
but so i don't know
i feel like that pisses people off he
always says lazy bones
let me point you to the right card
directions right over there yeah um
work for the cardinals look at your card
right now rolling away throughout the
world oh he's got a point dude you
didn't i'm gonna make a heroic move and
save it for you sir
he's got he's got a point bro your cart
is rolling away
you got busted big time dude
actually it's like it's a bite's a duty
i do for myself you want to take it from
here sir yeah thank you very much
you're pretty brave thank you sir i
appreciate that he's right it's you know
it's for a mission it's a risk we take
every time we put on the uniform but uh
i see anybody get a bigger bulletproof
vest brother what's that
i'm just saying people are crazy out
here bro oh that's okay he's kind of
right we run away
thank you for returning your card so
it's a big deal a lot of people don't do
that so i appreciate that sir yeah he
and i'd say props to the for you know
but you got to think if you're having
like the shittiest day and you're going
to the grocery store over the top that's
that's what happened to the last guy
but he's right you should put your card
back and i always do where are you on
this alignment chart
so return to the store no who would do
that
somebody's lawful good
i i returned to the corral corral i
don't well i can launch into the crowd
depending on i was going to say
i'm definitely chaotic good i always
launched that yeah if if there's a good
runway yeah yeah yeah
return to another start
return to the poor
return to nature
unreturned but neatly stacked is
lawfully evil
okay okay leaving the parking spot and
chaotic evil as you throw it in the uh
in the watch
okay that's funny
that's funny especially all the evil
ones i've seen like every every time you
go sure
uh this is great car knocks at your
service bye
man this guy is next level dude he is
brave doing that though because you
never know man pissing someone off like
that
there's one more
and then we'll we'll talk to the legend
this free-spirited young lady
i believe is doing the thing that we
always see when people park at the very
far end of the parking lot as they
so this is a different carton agent
i believe there's two of them wait are
you serious yeah they've they've
expanded to the east coast so no way
florida the og is the one here on the
west coast okay i didn't know i've never
seen previous videos we were watching
but yeah this is uh this is their other
chapter holy
yeah
so we'll be speaking to uh sebastian
he's the founder right yes right he's
the one i wanted the og yes
okay well i don't care about this guy
i'm a sebastian stan okay
yeah but they've they're on instagram
300 000 followers
um
look at his thumbnails what the [ __ ]
and of course i found him on tick-tock
which is where i find all good things
these days how many of our guests have
we found on tick tock it's pretty
amazing
quite a few yeah found wally on tick
tock
martin martin
carton arc
but basically here
i swear to god
[ __ ] you forever dude for that
yeah
oh yeah i will as soon as you take
how do i
zoom dude why does it do that bro
cause you're scrolling
i'm not i'm just trying to zoom in
[Music]
oh yeah i will as soon as you take your
carpet i'm gonna call the scorer right
now
well you need to get rid of it yeah
irresponsible shoppers that are blind i
will not shop here anymore i don't work
for the store who are you my name's
agent sebastian i'm the powerful and
sexy car nut oh my god yeah
oh yeah i will as soon as you
there's ones where he even puts it on
the windshield
uh as they're driving off smart man who
gets it but i gotta go where what's
what's such a rush for so what's your
big food half hour drive oh i'm going to
give you a bumper magnet shane lazy hey
i'll put this okay wait this is a good
one man who gets it but i gotta go where
what's what's you such a rush for so
what's your big deal food half hour
drive oh i'm gonna give you a bumper
magnet a shame lazy bones says what says
lazy oh take that don't be bow you stop
well i'm giving you one anyway i love
this man but it is maggie yes if there's
a magnet how dare you sir you're mocking
the card to our face
i'm gonna put it on you i'm gonna put on
the back some people know you're lazy
a smart man i always return my card but
i do have a hard time understanding that
people get so triggered because if if
this happened to me i would be [ __ ]
laughing my ass off if a guy was coming
i think if you're just having a bad day
i guess like that one would just kind of
be like okay dude and drive off but yeah
well i've seen when people try to drive
off he puts the magnet in front of them
on the windshield so they have to get
out and take them back probably a little
too far and then
i'm a killer i'm trying to find that one
this guy's threatening to kill him so
that's epic
there you go sir right there
sure what's the problem
why would you do that i'm fixing to kill
you
a piece of [ __ ] i am too sir uh block
your attack sir thank you i'm a good
dodger yes sir can you just take your
cart back
share my carton arc
agent cordell and i'm a killer well sir
that's not nice
about six right in your point here sir
that's against the law i don't give a
damn what you did is harassment
there you go sir right there
people get so angry about it but there
you go
just to give you an idea of what he does
he is the carton arc
the one and only
i really want to climb more
now i went through his whole tick tock i
didn't see
i'm not sure if this is his official
tick tock or this is just eclipse one
but i didn't see any on the windshield
oh my god i can't do this
i can't do this tick tock
how do i zoom in
people can't see it's too small
see what happens when you leave your
card out keep it on and i'm gonna change
your way put another [ __ ] [ __ ]
on there and i'm gonna tell you i don't
yeah okay let's get them on i have i
have a lot of questions for the carton
sebastian right now
so there you guys have it this is a true
visionary uh among us
a brave warrior uh one might even say
true truly brave
on the holy mission
stand by
and here we are there is sebastian
everybody
so you are the founder of kart arcs
yes i am the uh the main the head agent
in charge yes
and so and so if you're wearing a
bulletproof vest of some sort
yeah i didn't start off this way it was
just uh just me initially and i had a
t-shirt and i had like a little little
uh tech vest and then after a guy pulled
a gun at me is that right
an officer who's a fan in baton rouge
louisiana sent me one of his spare
bulletproof vests just happened to fit
uh perfectly and so when someone pulled
a gun on you did you not think like
maybe this isn't worth it anymore
uh
no because that's how they you know i
don't want to use the whole like
terrorist angle but that's how they win
is when you give up
when they use fear intimidation threats
and violence that's when they win they
think and i had this conversation with
somebody the other day after some guy
pulled out like a nightclub sort of
thing on me
and he's like man just stop and i said
well then they will know that that's
that's kind of the behavior
so who is there
uh the lazy bones right the lazy the war
against the lazy bones right the people
who will leave their card out
and then when reminded politely may i
say by someone like myself hey that
doesn't go there
they then
don't say oh i'm sorry they say oh at
you
yeah let me ask you a question did they
um did a stray uh shopping cart kill
your mom or something
what could create someone so passionate
about uh the putting the carts in the
corral
actually it was uh in high school i was
bitten by a radioactive cart oh that
explains it
yeah right no uh it was it was honestly
it's super super monday it was just
myself and a conversation with the guy
in the office one day about
common courtesies and he's very like ocd
type of person as far as picking up and
being clean about new things
and we're just talking about littering
and picking up after your dog and
holding the door for people
uh not farting in an elevator is one of
the funnier ones i guess
but like stuff that isn't necessarily a
law or doesn't really get enforced as a
law
but you know you should be doing and
shopping carts were the one where we're
like oh well that all happens in one
area so we don't like wait for someone
to litter for instance or throw a
cigarette butt on the ground just go to
a shopping cart or do a parking lot i
should say
so you're looking for
you started with the idea to
look for people being inconsiderate
and you decided well the the carts is
the best place to find and actively
confront these people
right and it started i got a little over
three years ago where
i just walked up to people and said oh
hey why'd you do that i didn't have all
the the bulletproof vests and the
magnets and this you know the siren all
that get up and stuff
and what kind of kept it going was
people got so angry and so defensive off
the bat i'm like wait hold
all i did was ask but then they throw
all the excuses they threatened me
uh like some of our older videos people
will say oh gosh there wasn't even any
uh like you didn't put a magnet on
anybody's car or anything like no
because i didn't number one i didn't
have them and number two it's all you
take sometimes and say oh that's not
where that belongs to people
some people i should say lash out
well that yeah that's that that so were
you filming it the first time you did it
or was all just love for the game
well no this did come off of a
sort of a bit idea or i work for a radio
show here in l.a okay okay and so i i do
a lot of stuff that like i visit uh i do
a lot of on the street stuff or visiting
actual locations
uh so
because everybody's had this observation
you go back on twitter for 10 years and
people are pissed off about people
leaving shopping carts but i'm i'm sort
of a guy who puts his hands in the in
the pie so to speak get his hands dirty
uh yes that's that's how it all started
there are you like a comedian or an
entertainer do you see yourself as
anything like that or
yes that is what i try to do is put a
comedic spin on things you know with
like the silly
names i'm calling people and just like
the very over-the-top ridiculous way i
do things
kind of helps highlight i'm being so
silly and they're being so angry so like
i think if i went out and like yelled at
people and cussed at them i wouldn't
you know the the the hero villain
dichotomy wouldn't really be there
right right right
and how often are you going out there
you go out there by yourself do you ever
feel like this is a little nuts like
you're in there by yourself with all
this cra crazy stuff confronting
unsuspecting people over a cart
do you ever ask yourself like what am i
doing here
right how do we get to this point in our
lives yeah
yeah this is my life has become
uh you know that has come up but and i
very rarely will have quote backup or
assistance
um just because i think
it helps me keep you know
more on my toes you know i don't have
that out that ripcord i can pull so i
kind of have to keep up with things and
just kind of handle myself in that
respect so yeah there's no bodyguard
there's no camera crew or anything like
that uh every once in a while i have a
spotter i'm like milwaukee but uh you
know other than that nobody else is out
there
well so it turned into kind of a whole
business for you eh i mean you got the
carton arc thing now you got the channel
you have different chapters of carton
arcs now apparently right on the east
coast
yeah there's a global community boston i
have been to the uk to australia it's uh
because we get reports from those places
people will send us pictures and videos
you know instagram or whatever say god
you gotta come to my location and you
know fill in the blank wherever and uh
we'll be there because we don't want
lazy bones to feel like there's one area
where they're going to be safe like
there's no cardinals there we'll be in
hawaii and we'll be in you know
massachusetts at any time you don't know
you never know so where where do you
think
people are the angriest where have you
found the angriest people in the world
i'd say overall
the angriest slash most willing to fight
are is las vegas actually i don't know
what it is about
yeah and i i noticed that too in other
uh desert cities like tucson like
phoenix albuquerque
i don't know what attracts like these
like sort of like scaly lizard people to
those areas
i don't know if it's the best
well you just you see i just see
i drive i'm not just at the airport and
a hotel
every part of every one of these cities
and just driving around there it's just
like everybody looks miserable and when
i get out to talk to them
you know they're they're angry they're
wanting to fight me i i don't know i
guess the heat or whatever but yeah it's
not fun
and is this your full-time job are you a
full-time carton arc now uh no it could
be but i try to keep it as more just uh
like a i don't know a hobby or a public
service where i'm doing it mostly
weekends mostly afternoons we don't do
it after dark because we don't want to
think of
park it up on one of those scissor lifts
and you have to do carton arts after
dark um
but yeah it's more like it's like you go
out the weekend and pick up the
literature you know this the little
league field near your house that sort
of thing but uh but international
ma'am i wonder if you really are
striking fear into the hearts of uh
cart bandits i think everybody in here
i'm thinking we're all thinking i'm nev
i'm putting that card in every time
they're always performing and i'm sure
we all have always none of us have ever
left the card out that would be
outrageous you you taught me to do so uh
sebastian you reformed zach i'm fearful
of you coming up to me
and may i say it's a it's a very low
grade fear it's not because i've never
hurt anybody no it's the humiliation
yeah it's just and that's what i tell
people we are social creatures we learn
how to do by watching our mom and her
dad and our parents our friends or
whatever
which is why like you don't see this
sort of thing in japan
you don't see it in like the uh like
norway i get reports from people all
these places photos and videos like this
would never happen here because we just
don't do that because it's not the kind
of people we are interested but
and so that's why when i was on i was on
dr phil last year and he's like well
shaving doesn't work absolutely shady
works he told you that
oh yeah well his oh he was
at segment after segment guest after
guest was trying to tell me what i was
doing was wrong
oh no dr phil
yeah you know what i you know what dr
phil probably done put his cart back
that's what it's telling me yeah exactly
and i i told him at one point like i
expected better of you you know you know
better than this because his whole deal
is he's gonna tell it like it is and
give you the straight talk he's not
gonna let you get away with anything you
know excuse-wise but he was nothing but
excuses um yeah well
dr phil really is not the moral
center of anything he's kind of a weird
dude and
apparently yeah
yeah so so you were kind of at work can
we pull up that clip i want to see you
on dr phil you kind of got like a
condensed version on their youtube page
yeah i'd love to see that so you kind of
got into it yeah [ __ ] dr phil
well he had two big arguments one yeah
go ahead you you recap it yeah what is
two big arguments one was well you don't
know where people go are going through
in their lives as if
first off i do because i ask people
because they'll say they'll give me an
excuse like oh i'm in a hurry and i'll
say to do what to commit you know to
cure cancer to so you got heart surgery
waiting no they never are it's always a
lie um so i did a an experiment after
that episode where i went out as agent
mcgraw and i just was like i would go to
people i wave like a five dollar bill
and they left their card out and say i
bet you had a real good because that
would get their attention and i'd say i
bet you had a real good excuse why you
didn't take your card back and they were
like i didn't feel like it it was never
and i'd say we'll give you five dollars
if you take it back and then build and
negotiate how about ten dollars or
whatever yeah really yeah
it's never never once has ever had i had
a great excuse and then these other
other fallacy that he tried to throw at
me was well they're a lot more important
things you could be working on and i and
of course the audience yeah and i turned
the audience and i said
how many of you this morning went to a
soup kitchen to feed the homeless
because that was one of the options he
brought up and they were oh we don't
have no you decided to go to dr phil
because not everything is heart surgery
and curing cancer and uh you know this
vampire nuclear bomb you know well
everybody needs a hero and uh the carts
need their hero and you're basically the
batman of returning shopping cards you
strike fear
into the hearts of villains like batman
and you don't need to be everywhere they
just need to fear you that you're there
you know here's
i mean here's dr phil with a shopping
cart and now i don't know if he
necessarily returned that correctly but
based on how he reacted to you on his
show i'm willing to guess that this man
does not return his cart
i would guess not and some people i
don't i don't support this but people
have considered or said they would take
a bunch of carts to his mansion in bel
air and dump him on his part in his uh
driveway again i can't recommend that
that's you know littering
uh but it's you think he steals cards
oh who knows yeah this man this man is
clearly unhinged in the wild person yeah
well wow i can't believe they brought
you on and and tried to confront you
like that that's just not right i mean
here we celebrate you uh we we celebrate
your achievements and uh we recognize
your heroism
you very much and it's one of those
things it's indefensible ultimately if
there's no case against doing it uh
there's a famous you know meme written
about like unless you're unless you just
broke your ankle you know like all the
things i'm talking about or you just had
your appendix first there's really not a
good reason
is there anyone that you kind of
got into it with that you felt bad about
it afterwards like that one guy i don't
were you watching the show before you
came on i know i didn't know it wasn't
possible
there's that really famous one i'm a fat
a-hole
like that guy was about to freaking lose
it like do you ever feel bad for them or
you're like i [ __ ] them
well i do i feel bad like there was that
that guy i'm a fatty whole guy and there
was a guy who recently he was it was in
palm springs he was chasing me around
his corvette and he was jiggling all
over the place yeah uh to the point that
he said i'm gonna kick your ass after
you mother effort come here the cracker
he called me the c word um
and i said well you might even put a bra
on before you beat me up sir oh
and i knew he got roasted so hard and
like the guy you're talking about he was
like on the verge of tears and other
people like that
but then i think like
i didn't do this to them they have
worked themselves up to this degree
because there are plenty of videos where
they just are like oh you're right sorry
about that
they
you you control your own feelings unless
i'm torturing you and your family you
control how you feel about this right i
guess
it's a side experiment i guess in human
it is like it really is you need a you
need a case study
you need scientists trailing you yeah
right
so yeah i do feel i feel bad but like
again they're doing this to themselves
quite literally
um what's the what percentage of people
would you say are polite
are just like oh i'm sorry about that
let me put it back
probably about 25
oh wow i've gotten to the point now
to try to like because people will say
that i'm that i'm instigating or
harassing to the point that so i try to
tag one of those people on the end of
every video to show that you could be
like this person who pulls this gun on
me and chasing me around with a taser or
whatever or you could be like this other
person who just said ah my bad no big
deal so that's 25
yeah so so break it down for me so 25
are polite all good like break down the
percentages for me yeah it's about 25
who are like yeah whatever that's cool
about 25 who just drive off who either
they think of a maniac or but i'm not
dressed like this and i identify what
you can see in the videos
to be fair you do look like a maniac
yeah this is just
an outfit
and when i point to the car point to the
carpet chart i make it very clear
where and what's going on that i'm not
trying to rob them or solicit them or
anything like that can i ask you so do
you owe it if they try to drive off do
you always put on the magnet
if possible yeah
and so they drive off with the magnet on
them right because it's twofold and i'll
show one for folks you guys can see that
this is a version of it says lazy bones
on board
and below that what i'm covering up is
our phone number um
two reasons one they can call us and
hopefully say they're sorry which hasn't
happened yet
has anyone called
oh yeah there's a there's an episode
fairly recently with um it's sort of
controversial
with uh in l.a with a guy named perry
caravello
who is known uh at least amongst the l.a
comedian crowd for a movie he did it
called windy city heat on comedy central
with jimmy kimmel and blah blah blah a
lot of people involved well he's like a
known a-hole you know
and i knew some people who knew and he
was
talking about how he doesn't return
cards blah blah blah and so i knew where
he was going to be thanks to some inside
information he did not know i was going
to be there
and i threw one and i stuck one of these
on the end after he chased me around
trying to beat me up and he left like a
two and a half minute voicemail
you know awesome
but now there's conspiracy about they
say oh perry's an entertainer i promise
you if you learn more about this guy
can i listen to the um i want to uh
what's the name of that i want to listen
to it oh i believe it is called fanny
packer because he wears a giant fanny
pack like industrial great fanny pack
yeah so if you scrub to the end of that
or not the end of it about two-thirds
through that uh video uh you'll still
see a pop-up a little table pop-up oh my
goodness and what's his name i'm gonna
pull up his picture says perry caravello
his uh
again he's he's bang you think of him
like uh if you ever watch not watch or
listen to the howard stern show like
members of his backpack that is very
much what perry is like he is
he's a
wannabe entertainer want to be comedian
so that's why people kind of have
various oh is this the guy they made
like a parody video about
or they made a parody movie with that
yeah where he they thought they
he thought he was a celebrity and they
were [ __ ] with them all the time okay
and so he's still gonna do it and trust
those same guys i mean i was with jimmy
kimmel people back in the late 90s
because he would he would show up to
comedy shows like uh open mics back in
the day like the comedy store and stuff
and the guys were like oh my god who was
this psycho and so they kind of adopted
him as a character and that's
and so he but he's still doing stuff
nowadays um and that's why he's still in
the public zeitgeist to some degree so
do we find the i thought i think i just
found it all right i want to play this i
want to play this recording
that's so funny that you were able to
track him down that's kind of wild dude
return
please return card
yeah if you scrub through about uh two
or three minutes just pop right up there
but yeah he's uh again he's known uh he
does like uh
he's it's a such a long story but like
he does a live stream now that is
managed by other people like he doesn't
produce any of his own content he's just
kind of
a reactionary sort of guy
this got age restricted why did it get
age restricted well there's a lot of
death threats involved oh my goodness
uh he is yeah he's not a kind person
holy smokes
goodness gracious
let me get a little taste just got back
from costco my name is perry caravello
uh costco and on support little
boulevard they're in van nuys
you're carton art punk
he's lucky i didn't catch him and beat
his [ __ ] ass do not ever
ever ever put a [ __ ] magnet on my
[ __ ] car again you [ __ ] suckers
that's awesome he's like a sam tennessee
holy
there's a 30-year rabbit hole again back
to jimmy kimmel in the 90s before he was
even famous of this perry guy
so
we've got 25 percent who are play 25 who
just ignore so
keep breaking it down for me the other
50
is probably 50 50. where 25 for the
other 25 of those who will give me some
lip will tell me to f off we'll
try to make a couple of excuses but
ultimately they kind of give up you know
they're like they they'll maybe take one
magnet and throw it on the ground
uh and i'm gonna put the second magnet
on they're just like i can't you know
they're done because i probably defused
whatever excuse they have uh you know
they might say well they paid people to
take the cards and i might say
well yeah from the cart return not just
in the middle of the spot where you left
it
and then they kind of that's the end of
their argument there and then the other
25 are the violent ones who will chase
threaten
try to run me over with their car which
has happened a couple of different times
um you know and up to no one ever fired
a bullet so i've got that going for me
so far i've had one gun drawn
two other guys threatened to pull a gun
uh one of those guys had shot a man
previously we found out later uh what
happened there this was in texas
uh outside of dallas where a guy
he comes out of the car and he's like uh
he's who are you and i'm you know i'm a
partner as well he's then he goes well
i'm a killer
uh i'll put six in your forehead and i
was like oh that doesn't sound like an
extreme reaction to a magnet on your car
well he so that video comes out and then
within a week or like that guy was on
the news last year because he was on a
dallas area train which i didn't realize
they have like a subway system
and apparently he shot a guy who he
claimed was harassing women
i believe that guy survived
this video of him being arrested as he
asked the train he got out a year later
uh roughly it was a year prior to when
he approached me so
he when he says i'm a killer and i'll
put six in your forehead he has previous
experience shooting people in public but
like how do you shoot people and get out
a year later only in texas i assume he
was never arrested i should clarify that
but he's a he's a wanted criminal no no
he was they didn't press charges
because i they said they didn't have
camera a camera system on that train at
the time the [ __ ] you're not getting
charges pressed
for shooting someone
that's crazy well
yeah so that that's uh i gotta say
25
seems very large for people to react
violently that does that scare you that
so many people are ready to get violent
that's a staggeringly high amount i well
i think they are
i'm trying to it's to me it's the
analogy of like if if a dog catches a
the car
what are they gonna do you know
they they like to propose that they're
gonna act violent you see this at
sporting events and bars they like to
buff up or [ __ ] up i should say and like
and and look like they're gonna be tough
but i i don't think they would actually
get into a real fistfight nor would i
get into one whether or not i can beat
them up or not cause i'm not going to
hurt somebody over a shopping cart but i
think a lot of that is posturing i think
the i'm going to f you up sort of stuff
is is more words than anything else
so
ultimately but it seems like your life
has been threatened seriously you've
been trapped you've been had two uh two
guns pulled on you a few people have
tried to run you over in a car
knives have been pulled on you i'm
assuming pepper spray anything like that
pepper spray taser there's only one
knife that's been pulled but it was you
it was the craziest thing this guy who i
later realized was most definitely a
member of the crypt gang uh crips again
i should say in long beach
he gets out of his car he's in blue
shirt blue bandana blue jeans
and i put the magnet on the front of his
on his
knife
where he's like taking he's like getting
the knife to remove the
uh magnet which then i also realized oh
here's one his fingerprints on this
magnet
at the time and i i mean i'm narrating
all these videos as i'm going along and
i was very clear like i don't think he
struck me with this knife he's just
using it to remove the magnet
um but then i was like now i look back
like oh he's in all blue head to toe
he's got a knife here's someone oh okay
we're out we're in long beach oh okay
i'm putting two and two together as far
as this guy was but no he did not
threaten me with a knife
per se but aren't you you're clearly
putting yourself in in danger i feel
like that's for sure like i mean you're
gonna go across the wrong person and
they might shoot you is it worth it
that's a good question and uh i forget
what the movie is might have been
gladiator when they say uh yes
all men die but not all men truly live
you know
you might
say oh that's stupid what do you you
know you want your mom going to your
funeral because some guy like you said
shots over shopping cart and um you know
i don't obviously but again i think i
think there's so much bluster and
puffery
um
and when you think about when you really
think about other risks in your life as
far as how many people die under the
roads every year and
so on and so forth um you know i i think
i think it's ultimately a relatively low
risk for as dangerous as it does which i
agree well
you're in it for the game you're ready
to die for this you know what i mean
i'll take a bullet for a card right
that's that's what i'm hearing it's not
the best my obviously your face is never
bulletproof obviously so
well sebastian
keep lit keep living the the fight in
the good fight is there any uh future
projects we should look forward to is
there any other inc uh uh rude kind of
sub dramas you're thinking of of
branching out into
one that's really been uh grinding my
gears today i'm family guy uh is people
who don't rack their way to the gym
recently uh okay
because and i see it i have a nice new
gym in my place i live in and you go get
the barbell off with the dumbbell off
the uh the rack and it just goes on the
floor and it like no it's got it where
it says 25 put it back okay okay i need
to get a gym that will allow me to put
cameras inside and you know dude so on
and so forth the gym sounds interesting
because you know those guys are all oh
you're going to be a lot of
hyper masculine meat heads so it could
be going down there for sure
right again same idea where people don't
want to look stupid in front of whatever
so i don't know what my outfit will be
if you'll be
the best as well there wouldn't be as
helpful but uh that's if you are a gym
owner and you don't mind uh playing a
little bit of a having a little fun with
some of your patrons
find my contact info out there
i would absolutely
love to see that and hopefully they're
out there
well sebastian you are a man who has
dedicated his life to a craft
he has risked life and limp to
strike fear in the hearts of all
villains who had not returned their car
and let it be known everybody watching
that he could be lurking anywhere in any
place
any time yep so you better
return that not at night yeah so return
that cart guys
carton arc's basically everywhere right
tik tok twitter instagram fun fact not
on tick tock oh so that wasn't you
that was a lot of videos around there
but i have been uh booted off tick tock
because
apparently they claim that my the
activities i engage in could put myself
in harm's way and they don't want to be
you know like they don't want to be like
the next cinnamon challenge i guess for
the teenagers that is interesting and uh
they're not necessarily wrong about that
yeah but there are videos of mine out
there with i got hundreds of thousands
of views millions fan accounts oh yeah
oh yeah yeah and how people approach me
in lots and say hey i saw you tic talk
and i'm like well sort of that's how i
found you we're just fine i don't mind
it you know how long the words getting
out there the word is out so but but
your main your main source of uploading
is on youtube carton arcs yeah yeah it's
it's uh it's the easiest one to search
on too as far as by date by view count
there you have it guys
sebastian
what does your family think about what
you do are they worried about you
i i had i didn't tell him but my mom
found out she was getting a
new cell phone and we have a very odd
last name and for whatever reason she
was having to google something or search
something and then the cell phone repair
man or salesman said oh that's the
cardinal guy and she's like what's that
and then uh
but she's a fan she she's a she's around
dr phil
your mom supports the cause
yeah absolutely oh wow
what would you do if you found your mom
not returning the cart like like and
while you were out in the wild what
would you do
well i mean i would shame her obviously
yeah she has to be shamed that's yeah
there's no exception for
family members by no means no hopefully
she wouldn't try to run me over yeah you
never know
maybe she was having a bad day
sebastian of carton arcs thanks for
calling in
i really appreciate hearing your story
thanks for sharing that with us
all right keep going keep dodging those
bullets and stay safe all right
thanks guys all right
there it is partners
this man lives
some men
well what did he say from gladiators
all men die but not all men live there
it is
this man lives on the edge
he is on the edge man this guy
i i would be scared to go out there i'll
just be honest this man has had two guns
pulled on him i mean he's he's out there
doing it he's got my cajones for doing
it man i think he needs a superhero
costume like with a cape oh
you know what you mentioned batman maybe
he should just dress up as batman then
people will be less you know offended by
it they'll know it's more of a bit
a whole batman get up mm-hmm i don't
know i feel like if he rolls up wearing
his outfit he's wearing now i'd be like
okay this is this is funny this is
interesting
well you said that he intimidated you
into uh changing your ways oh yeah but i
i don't wait and you're you're a joker
brained yeah it makes perfect sense
batman yeah he curbed me yeah
that's what i'm saying because batman he
he strikes fear in the hearts
[Music]
what are you guys saying you want to
pull about and people are saying paul i
don't know what you what what well
the community's
torn that's he's a polarizing figure
it's this has been a polarizing uh
whole segment because there's a lot of
love for carton art and there's you know
a lot of people that
think he's got cop energy and oh well he
has an ark in the title i don't think he
hides from it i mean he's by def he is
by a self-emitted narc right
you know identifying yeah um i mean we
can do a poll right like what what
is he a is he a cab is he right yeah
you know what i mean
yeah we can do a poll so do you support
carton arc yes or no do you support
kart narc's mission or just him in
general him
hey cab cartmark to be honest it's if
i'm being totally honest
it's funny and entertaining it's pretty
crazy what he does
and i think i was i was relatively
upfront about that with him no you were
upfront about it and i mean i agree with
you if if that if those stats are
accurate
25 one in four people is like getting
violent with him i mean
it's just a numbers game you're going
doing that all the time
he's gonna get hurt yeah he's gonna get
hurt eventually i mean once
once someone pulled a gun on me i'd
probably call it a day right yeah you
know um
all right i'm throwing up the poll
standby well i i honestly if i have to
vote on this seriously
i'm right in the middle man
well
after after speak oh you hear love love
is fully in support i'm voting yes
because love you you said because he
mentioned norway um yeah but you said in
our chat that's the same in sweden like
in sweden nobody leaves their card out
is that true yeah i mean you'd be like
cast out of society if you did is that
bad
i mean i've never ever seen it and i
cannot imagine ever doing it right so
let me ask you this do they have the
cart corral or do you have to bring it
back in the store
yeah they have uh crawls yeah okay yeah
wow that's so interesting insane to me
that you wouldn't return your car like
come on bro well do you have people that
come and collect the carts i mean no
because there's no cars no
yeah i don't know what's going on here
in america
but people get complacent because
there's cart collectors but which came
first the car collector or the cart
lever oh interesting now we're stuck in
a second quarters
oh see that's why they got you no you
they're free here
see that's a yeah that's an oversight
yeah you got to put in a court put in
quarters you unlock it and then you you
put it back and you get your quarterback
yeah and it's not even a quarter it's
like 0.005 dollars or you have these
plastic bits that you put on your
keychain
um see i'm not sure i like the free card
i'll be honest with you
i'm offended oh people would absolutely
[ __ ] riot yeah i would [ __ ] i
would like they should people would
originally love let me explain to you if
they tried to put coins in a cart they
would burn that [ __ ] down do you
understand now that's an affront to
freedom
some people saying uh
aldi is it aldi aldi aldi yeah yeah we
don't have those here in uh la or very
few of them you at aldi you get the
quarterback though like right put it in
yeah so some places in america do do in
israel they do that too by the way you
have to put a coin in okay they're
everywhere about america does that
i'm just gonna lie interesting
yeah but you i don't know i i don't know
if in your time here love but carts they
show up everywhere they're in [ __ ]
streets and corners and people's
backyards and and
and creeks you know what i mean there's
cars everywhere even wally had a cart in
his house so oh yeah they may do it uh
places
other than america but i do have to say
usa number one the inventor of the
shopping cart an american that's right
we
are the best that's an awesome invention
it's just a little cart with wheels how
do you get how do you get i don't know
credit for that
baby a jew also invented it you know
round of applause for that are you sure
you're just making that because his last
name is goldman i mean oh it says oh
yeah he's a dude
yeah of course a jew invented the
shopping cart where you have to put a
little coin in it
anyway i afforded yes i am in support of
the carton arc
a clear third of the audience though or
just shy of a third of the audience is
not supporting so yeah
you know it's it is a little
controversial it is a little
controversial
okay he's committed man it's kind of
incredible
[Applause]
what an interesting character eh
there you have it
the carton arc ladies and gentlemen
meanwhile
people say oh why do you care about
carts when there's like stuff going on
in ukraine
you could be
you could be helping out people in
ukraine well here is what's going on in
ukraine
and kart if cartnock was here maybe he
could have helped but you guys saw him
that's awesome
what a terrible way to pass off a body
like it's a couch
you know like when you're moving
you dangle the couch over
if it falls it falls oh my god but with
a human body oh it's terrible
he doesn't care
did he barely even uh makes an attempt
to rescue him
look how slow he is to act the guy on
the ground
he's like oh all right well
i guess i'll
pick him up
he's face down in the snow
damn terrible
guys
sorry
i'm sure he's fine
i'm sure he's fine
you know
i'm sure he's fine
i think that
the injured guy was probably better off
before calling the rescue team oh for
sure
that's for sure
the new leslie nielsen clip is that oj
in the stretcher what does that mean
it's a naked gun reference
okay i see where
oj's character in that movie is
constantly getting like thrown off the
got it got it
so that's fun that's what's going on
a new spider-man fail just dropped you
know i love these
oh this is the disney one yeah yeah now
is this one real because the last one
was fake so the last one was fake and
i that made me very skeptical of this
but uh there's lots of articles written
about and stuff okay here we go
spiderman at disneyland
that looked like a dude that looks
horrible oh
that's fun
that's what i'm talking about because
this sounds pretty stupendous dude what
happened spidey
spidey had a seizure quick get the
camera
is it muted
[Music]
that's definitely fake
wait you think it's fake
yeah they look real i'm just what do you
know it looks it looks the last one
looked fake as hell
this one looks really given i've seen
the behind the scenes of some dude
making this video well hold on because
there was one just like this that was
fake i had the same but it was different
i had the same thought process loving
and i did some digging and i i think
that this one really happened
oh there's pictures of them repairing it
look at that thing dude
whoops
that would be way cooler to see that
than the real show you know
so
this is the s the fake one yeah this is
the fake one love that you might be
referring to
oh it's the same place yeah then it's
probably
yeah
so and then this is the real one
he breaks this [ __ ]
[Music]
dan's saying it's real
i mean unless they fooled a bunch of uh
uh newspapers and stuff too because
there's there's a bunch of guys we know
that we know it's animatronic yes it's
not a person
what what
i didn't oh that was a person okay
i thought the first one when i saw the
first fake one i was like oh my god
they have a it's like a
some crazy animatronic they built where
it does yeah every hour
looks really cool like wow what a yeah
what a true gymnast
super talented
well that would be horrific if that was
a real person
joe biden speaking of falling lots of
accidents today
joe biden um
his administration is crumbling
did this this actually became like a big
story on conservative media yeah of
course that's so awesome
yeah so joe biden fell off his bike
[Music]
he misplaced his foot and just tumbled
over which is funny
but like let's be real this could happen
to anyone right
yeah so he has these like uh
the pedal has it's a locking walk-in
thing or whatever yeah and you got
messed up by that yo i don't like those
lock-ins that's pretty ballsy for a 79
year old man yeah i was gonna put him
i'm surprised the secret service let him
lock in
but uh
so so what what's the take uh from the
right they're they're losing it i'm sure
he's a senile old man uh yeah he's old i
would be honest
i'll be honest this makes me think he's
stronger than i thought because he got
up from that uninjured yeah if you were
really old that's a death sentence bro
there you go that's a broken head like
that yeah that's rip rest in concrete
and also i mean let's be real
can you imagine trump on a bicycle
donnie
that ain't happening if donnie fell on
off a bicycle he'd leave a crater behind
him
you seen that ass
okay
so let's watch this
this is another angle guys
[Applause]
it's just such a funny weird life
experience where you eat [ __ ] and the
whole world sees it it's embarrassing to
fall off your bike right like it's
humiliating well everybody saw it i love
it
getting a ride in his home state of
delaware today his foot got caught on it
happened in his home state of delaware
damn
damn damn
yeah yeah but obviously
listen apparently trump posted this in
response
okay sure what this is
[Music]
[Music]
epic meme
so wait zach you thought you loved it
jack i find it very happy i like it it's
so stupid
[Laughter]
[Music]
there you go that's donald trump our
next uh
our next uh
i didn't see
the stupid meme he posted but i did see
this
i make this pledge to you today i will
never ever ride a bicycle
you know that's how he wins
the man's got jokes he's not sick like
no other
he can't deny he may he may be a fascist
he may be a piece of [ __ ]
uh probably an r artist i make this
place
he brought back the funny to the white
house he's got jokes
you know he's got jokes that's why we
love him
he's a natural-born entertainer
i had to beat off not that i'm a big fan
of joe biden he's a
huge disappointment as a president in my
opinion
but
i don't think that falling from a bike
is evidence of uh
yeah oh no joe no
moments before disaster
how did he get in space just the wrong
way we got launched like the animatronic
and he's about to it was joe the whole
time
there you go
joe biden ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
is this more the same side is just more
oh my god now you know how i feel about
chiropractors these [ __ ] piss
me off they're always up to some dumb
[ __ ]
and this is no exception my friends now
this chiropractor is doing a sinus
crunch
you crack
guys let's be real what the [ __ ]
same side okay okay
what
that was in his mouth
it was coming out of his mouth that was
[ __ ] terrible are you [ __ ] serious
i didn't notice that the first time oh
he's holding a teddy bear yeah he better
hold that teddy bear he's got a balloon
coming out of his mouth from his nose oh
that was horrible the scream so so so
what if it breaks that's got to be a
horrific
surgery needing damage the balloon yeah
i mean
it's just a balloon
i mean
they do non-invasive balloon surgeries
in the nose for a variety of things but
i've never seen anything like this slay
med school
all right sometimes all right anyway
i can't get over this image
the chiropractors are such scam artists
they're like yo i can put a balloon in
the nose and it comes out the mouth i'm
sure that does something
[Laughter]
i watch cairo videos to relax sometimes
if i'm being you like the cracking i
love the cracking i get that jeff eckles
with his ring banger
you see that guy he like puts you in a
vice and like pulls your neck oh hit the
button dan let me show you my favorite
chiropractor i don't think the button is
set up no
but i know exactly what you're talking
about all right pull that up then
but holy [ __ ] man this poor guy and you
can you believe you're actually paying
someone to do this to you
like this is what you do to pows when
you're trying to
break their will not paying someone to
do it
he's got a gnarly sinus infection here's
a balloon yeah here here's the
chiropractors that i love here's what
they do
there's a new technology guys
yeah that that helps with that helps
with uh you know
back pain
displaced discs
anxiety sleep problems
what we do is we put you in on a bed and
we have four horses
run in opposite directions as fast as
possible
go ahead with it i want to see it again
uh
i don't know how to rewind on a youtube
short i'm not getting a progress bar
here maybe just loops
yeah just let it loop
come on
come on
they're leaving they're just going to
leave him there
they're like [ __ ] see you bro enjoy
dude we already saw the good part like
this video doesn't mean this is kind of
interesting though to see that
yeah so anyway
all right and get ready to
be cured
what
oh my god the world is so crazy guys
look at this
oh
it went out my mouth that time
same side okay dude what the hell
up um they made a balloon animal out of
his ass
boy
there you have that
oh [ __ ]
oh man this is kind of funny i'm sorry
but it is
somebody was at
some theme park yeah some amusement park
the story they tell is that they
took a bunch of edibles
and then saw keemstar with his
daughter yeah
assistant no girlfriend girlfriend
girlfriend it's not his daughter oh it's
his daughter
yeah no
oh it's his daughter yeah it's his
daughter
it's not his dog no i think it's his
girlfriend
yeah yes no it's his girlfriend it's
hard to tell the difference because
they're so close in age well assistant
assistant daughter wife well it was
father's wife it was father's day it was
father's day so you know that might yeah
oh it was a father's day trip yeah a
little father's day outing
the girl that could be his daughter
daddy so he was tripping balls
apparently he started taking photos
which i don't know it's kind of funny i
guess but wait there's more
why don't i only see one
this is no this was it that's all i wait
wait wait wait there's more there is
more if you go to his i'm busted
i saw more i'm sure of it maybe it's
down in the comments i i didn't catch
that
maybe he posted them separately
take a look
there was another one of him like
running
yo maybe it's in the comments yeah i'm
looking
i'm looking
uh
uh
well anyway
i'm sure i saw more about anything other
than this from what i'm seeing
maybe maybe you got goofed but he looks
real comfortable in his own skin super
youthful looking he's got a badanif
tightly sealed around his dome i was i
was asking where abe and i were talking
about it and abby's like how does he
leave it on during the roller coaster
i'm like he must glue it like a like a
hairpiece or something right that thing
is tight tight tight
i love that he does it down to the
eyebrow so you can't even get a peek of
that hairline you know what i mean
you can't even see his forehead oh oh
somebody coming through part two okay
good i knew there was a part two
blizzard woofie shot out
oh wait it was really did
oh yeah he was running past his kids off
the ride he was right it was a video of
him running off the ride
kind of funny but
coming with that heat
oh yeah
never forget that that's how he flirts
oh god
um we have a bunch of cups full of
balsamic vinegar next to us wait let me
do the embry okay you know what the
embrace masculinity will wait okay so
there is um
who's very familiar with this challenge
that can explain it well there's there's
a video you can just show it's in the
dock if you scroll down tick tock
healthy coke trend
yeah so people i've seen this on tick
tock in june a recipe for a healthy
alternative to coke went viral
all you do is mix balsamic vinegar and
soda water that sounds [ __ ] horrible
horrific ain't no way that tastes like
coke what are you talking about
do people just pretend to like it
i they might be trolling instructor
makes this drink
almost like every day i think she told
me and it's a healthy alternative to a
coke
and i am not joking you it tastes just
like a coke and you're gonna think i'm
insane so do you like a
splash no [ __ ] water with ice and a
cup i feel like we're getting and then
take any sparkling beverage it seems
like she does just a just a touch of
balsamic right
okay yeah you can do it let's see this
is gonna look this
yeah she put more than that yeah it like
goes up to near the top of the ice
give it a good yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i think that's good
you want more okay dan says more
just so what
i have it right here i guess mine
doesn't have that much yeah one more one
more tiny little splash here
okay there it is there it is there it is
so let's let's see what she says like i
know that this is [ __ ] and we're
being trolled
yeah but i'm not joking we gotta try it
tastes just like a coke and i think i'm
insane so do like a splash of balsamic
vinegar why just cause it's in a cup
and then take anything we did what she
did beverage
like i'm
what's similar the color i mean what
kind of scam is this
it's like saying [ __ ] tastes like
chocolate fudge
i mean it looks similar i guess but
it could be any flavor this one's the
guava it's like the summer you already
jumping in flavor
okay and now you're gonna mix it
together smells fine i guess see it
honestly already looks like a coke
but
i swear to god
it tastes like a coke and it's healthy
and it's good for you
you guys should try it out oh sushi okay
she does
so is this the question is is this just
a troll my pilates instructor makes this
drink
well cheers everybody everyone trick get
it
here we go is that for you lena what's
up okay cheers
bro there's kind of something to it
that's crazy
really i actually it actually i i
there's something to it
not coke holy [ __ ]
i feel like it's whatevs but it doesn't
taste like coke
you know that's kind be the same thing
to say [ __ ] universes this tastes
like a coke but why are you so desperate
just have a diet coke you
freak like you're putting balsamic and
soda it's not bad
balsamic
i have a
theory anyone saying that this actually
tastes like coke is using balsamic glaze
and not balsamic vinegar oh
a little sweetness yes yes yes that
could be that could be yeah lena tried
it at home first and she put a [ __ ] on
at first and it was [ __ ] horrid
oh yeah on the flavor lina can you talk
flavor yeah mike there they just pop
into your mic okay it's working okay
yeah i used unflavored water and then
now we have the actual flavor and i feel
like it made all the difference the
flavor helps definitely about it
okay you know what
i'm not going to say this is totally
myth-busted i'm saying
especially it's like coke though no no
no it doesn't taste like that's insane
should we try glaze yeah the glaze could
be
i mean i doubt it could be good some of
that in the kitchen though well i've got
some at home that i can obviously bring
in okay but for wednesday sure just a
continuation
let me watch this girl coca-cola it is
literally my life i have at least two a
day it's very problematic but i just
found out a way because it's problematic
it's been all over my for you page and
i'm gonna try to create you have to mix
balsamic vinegar
and any one of these
[Music]
i'm scared everyone makes it look like
it's so good but i'm gonna be honest and
real with you if it's disgusting but
it's the best thing ever
oh that doesn't smell good
it looks like
it's starting to smell like coke no it
doesn't
it for sure doesn't
okay ready
she put a lot
you put too much
so does anyone actually believe this
though i mean it's not bad but
really let me look at the first girl and
see if it's we can see if it's glazed or
not okay
okay my pilates instructor she shows the
bottle
yeah that's just straight up balsamic
yeah you can tell it's not that thick
but
i don't know i feel like anyone saying
that it tastes like coke it would have
to be the glaze but vin this vinegar is
not like sweet at all i'm saying yeah
about using glaze instead but it just
has sugar in it so you're just drinking
a sugary drink again right you might as
well just drink it so why don't we just
yeah because balsamic glaze is pretty
calorie
rich i don't know i know the glaze is
just reduced balsamic vinegar so
i don't know it's just like cooked down
oh is that right
well anyway guys it certainly doesn't
taste like coke and if you put a little
a small amount enough in it that you
can't really taste it it's drinkable i
don't hate it
i don't hate it either yeah it's not
which is kind of weird right yeah
unexpected it just it reminds me of an
italian restaurant which i don't hate
medallion all right thank you lena and
olive garden in this thank you for your
support and assistance on this matter
i'm drinking i'm gonna drink the whole
thing
are you really you're just going for it
it's nice it's refreshing it really is
what the [ __ ]
damn you never put a little balsamic in
your soda water
[Music]
you bring shame to my family [ __ ]
bubbly
i put the little balsamic
a little couple pubic hands
i know it was you afraid
a couple teardrops alfredo mix it up
it's a cocktail
you broke my heart
get this amount of coke zero dude yeah i
mean just drink a coke zero i don't
i don't even think those are bad for you
if i'm being honest
i think it's been busted
i don't think that
coke zero or diet coke is bad for you at
all i think it's been totally busted
totally debunked they've done tests
where your blood sugar doesn't even
spike at all when you drink the diet
cokes it's hydrating i think it's
totally totally busted that [ __ ] is safe
it's been linked to development of type
2 diabetes and heart disease that's a
bullsh that's an old study
what's that study from health line
health line who's that
it's uh
the leading
developer of writing lines about health
yeah lines
yeah if i need a line i'll uh hit up my
dealer
different line of coke
but if i need a coke
i ain't drinking this [ __ ]
cheers everyone's saying you're on
heavy copium with copium no i'm serious
there's a doctor i follow on twitter on
tick tock that tells me exactly what i
want
this is actually a good segue to
watching that clip in the beginning
because now this clip is going to be
used against you in a bunch of tick
tocks
right through wait let me find this guy
because he he tells it like it is guys
no i don't know what dude he's a dog
hold the [ __ ] phone guys
kokium
yeah i think that's what love said yeah
um he's this doctor on tick doc and he
goes time for school
and he's like
i'm so that's trying to find him time
for no he's the real deal dude and he
shows studies
i'm telling you guys bro it's not bad
for you
drink all the diet coke in the world
[Laughter]
dr copium
no
whoa
oh yeah wow
that's turning up
thank you to
michael valerie
five gifted subbies
oh if we're doing that i
wanna i didn't
want to interrupt earlier but trevor
smith donated
99.99 and said i work at a factory and
never get to watch you all live but i
took tonight off to watch y'all live oh
i love all of you and always remember
you got fans all night and day smiley
face what a legend thank you bro
i hope we didn't disappoint you with
this episode yeah this is the one you're
watching live yeah he unsubscribed he's
like he's not he's out he's doing it
he's he did a uh
he did a chargeback yeah
we'll do it live
someone said aspartame is like the worst
thing you could put in your body besides
meth gracie you're wrong i'm telling you
that [ __ ] is
you're wrong and i'm gonna find a tick
tock docker who says time for school
it's hard to find a doctor who says
school he's a big one he's a relatively
big tick tock doctor i think he's like a
person or pakistani
don't panic i'm not a crazy person wait
what's his name
dr what this might not be him
hold up dr james weiner is his name wait
i think i may have found him
yeah i found him
okay his name is dr ids idz
he's a medical doctor and a nutritional
research
so this guy's the real [ __ ]
deal
and now i'm going to find where he says
i'm not a time i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] no he
is a doctor [ __ ] [ __ ]
no people saying it's dr pepper
no it's not dog dr pepper is the real
deal [ __ ]
he's the real [ __ ] deal dr love the
kiss on
um dr demento
he has a lot of [ __ ] about um diet coke
is the worst thing you can drink here it
is
yo you guys are able to get [ __ ]
owned right now i found it all right
send it in i'm sending it to you guys
about to get your dick blown the [ __ ]
off or tits
yeah tits and dicks
gonna be blown the [ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ]
not [ __ ] dude
this is this is important though [ __ ]
okay here pull that up
you send him whatsapp i sure did
okay it didn't come through yet oh dr
lazybones
guys buckle in because your life's about
to change
go ahead
mm-hmm
he is not funded by the diet coke
companies
look how he's got his stethoscope on
chill
dr deus nuts
all right go ahead again love
i say what was the doctor's name dr
diese
these nuts
it is does that
coke is one of the worst things that you
can put in your body in fact it's
actually way worse than normal coca-cola
but it has something much more harmful
aspartame it feels like i need to debunk
this every month that's cool diet coke
is a much better alternative compared to
the normal sugary version and there is
practically no strong evidence for any
serious adverse effects first of all
zero calories means zero problems for
weight over 60 controlled trials are
shown in these meta analyses so it can
actually aid weight loss especially when
used to replace the sugary version and
no sweeteners don't spike your blood
glucose insulin or increase your risk of
and 10 cancer found no glycemic or
insulinemic responses and no association
with cancer but dr id sweeteners damage
the gut microbiome uh no this literature
review concluded that there is no clear
evidence of any adverse effects on the
microbiome that doses relevant to human
use but there is some evidence that
aspartame can affect your mood so if you
have low mood it's probably best to
avoid and speak to a doctor glass
dismissed
but okay what do you think well the man
he he has a stethoscope he's
good-looking he's got wearing scrubs
and he was pointing at some things in
the corner no no i'm convinced no stop
go to his pro this guy's the real md
sorry not what's your what's your source
dan
i don't have a i don't have a dog in
this fight i don't know
oh
maybe
thoughts
okay lena's brother who is a doctor um
whenever my new year's resolution was to
give up pop or a soda i was going to use
uh i was going to drink only diet soda
and he was telling me that it's still
very bad for you he's wrong he may be
wrong he hasn't done enough research
he hasn't done the
research idz has done
true yeah
i've choose to believe dr ids
wait is he is he even an md
yeah bro wait what does it say m it says
m wait what does mbbs mean an mres so
wait those aren't md's
but what are they exactly but it says
medical doctor yeah but so is a
chiropractor in a way but well what are
these what do what's under
undergrad med degree underground bro
what the [ __ ] and what's the other one
uh
i think peterson knows more about this i
think i have one of those
uh
what it says medical doctor right hold
on but it's not an md what's the other
one
he says undergrad that was worthless
okay we'll acknowledge that
uh
what the m what's that m
r e s masters of research
dude he's not enough he's not even a phd
what the [ __ ] i mean dan's right does
say doctor
and it says medical doc but you're blind
usually doctors put unless he's a do
then he might not want to show that he's
a doe because some people
he would have wrote
can
is a question
dude he's he wrote undergraduate and
master researcher this [ __ ]
ain't no goddamn doctor and how dare you
bro
i've been drinking 10 diet cokes a
[ __ ] day and my mood is [ __ ] no i'm
just kidding i i haven't started
consuming it more i have like one a day
at best
yo what the [ __ ] doctor ids
i would call that uh false advertising
i got zilli zonked by dr eds
well
do we think the master of research does
anything uh
help us here i mean maybe he researched
it a lot he clearly means clearly yeah
should we reach out and get him to call
in i would love that this is this is
something we need to sort
reach out to dr ed's it's gonna be time
we gotta
we're gonna have them call in to discuss
diet coke diet drink i feel like we need
someone from the other side too then to
actually talk about him yeah and that
would be an interesting debate
because
oh somebody uh just way coke is healthy
or not unhealthy in marble we could have
we could have lena's brother if we need
somewhere on the other side yeah
an indian fan of ours just donated 500
rupees and said mbbs is for indian
doctors okay interesting so he is a
doctor
okay so that's why wait wait wait so is
he is he an md
well there's different crediting in
different countries
he's a doctor okay okay i mean well
surgery is like it's
that doesn't necessarily no that that's
that's yeah not every doctor not every
doctor is right but i feel like medical
doctors when you're in he can prescribe
medicine right right but i feel like
when an ab correct me if i'm wrong but
when you're in med school to become an
md you have to learn all that anatomy
and perform some type of surgery
wait mbbs not every doctor does surgery
though right psychiatrist right right
and we're going to let a be anywhere
near that surgeon table with this you
know initially i was doing surgery no
my uncle told me i could do it because
my hands would be propped like there's
no [ __ ] way you were not gonna go to
school for 12 years and then kill
someone my first day
by the way people are saying mbbs is md
in the uk
oh okay well there you go see so would
your bro
would your brother call in to
debate dr eds yeah i'm sure he wouldn't
mind oh
her brother her brother's a fan of the
show
oh my goodness this could be a
fascinating conversation he's smart he
went to harvard and yeah no i've heard
about him he's apparently
a mega genius isn't that right lena mega
genius
yeah i would say that uh let's not scare
dr id's away
hey he's gonna back he's gonna he's to
back up his research man true
and he
he came out hot he's like i don't want
to have to explain this every day
so true actually this shit's not bad for
you
you know there's people doctors who said
like
smoking cigarettes wasn't bad
back in like the 18th right and they
right same with like the uranium in
watches
who like melted people's
well hold on that's why i said he's
bought off by big soda just like those
doctors were working well hold on
there are doctors that advocate for dumb
things but sometimes he's right there
are things that people think is bad for
you like in israel there's this weird
conspiracy that everyone in the whole
country believes that if you're on your
cell phone in the elevator it will fry
your brain or something and people will
literally yell at you if you're on your
phone in the elevator it's so weird so
i'm just saying there are a lot of
misconceptions sure
not everyone's young and healthy now
yeah i'm just saying i wouldn't trust
coke with anything
uh yes donald trump drinks like
30 gallons of diet coke a day and that
man is like almost 80 and he is in peak
physically let me tell you you're i i
don't know if you're kidding but he is
really remarkably his mental health is
sharp he's as sharp as ever he really is
if you compare him to joe biden he's
only a couple years younger than joe and
that man is way more presence mentally
than yeah cognizant i mean so there you
have it die coke is good for the mind
younger
yeah
yes so let's let's set that up can
someone reach out to dr edds actually
let me see if he follows me because i
follow him
yes let's see if we're buddies yes
are we friends dr eds no [ __ ]
cheap manipulation
so
i guess let's try to let's try to get
him they said my uncle was prescribed
cigarettes for stress in
the late 60s
that would make your stress so much
worse
there's a old camel ad camel cigarettes
for uh the number one cigarette by
doctors doctor smoking yeah
that's so cool
love that
all right
well
i can't wait for that debate let's let's
resolve this once and for all guys
uh
and angela
doodles actually makes a good point the
doctor was saying that as a replacement
diet coke was healthier than coke he
wasn't saying that diet coke is
not bad well no what he he said both he
said yeah he said as a replacement it's
much better than coke that actually by
itself is already a good point to make
because there's a lot of people that say
like oh well diet coke's probably even
worse for the new coke but then he said
there's almost no evidence at all that
that diet coke is even bad correct yeah
yeah and [ __ ] you
is this the one he was talking about or
diet coke this is they just put out this
new uh
variant just specifically for you ethan
no dude
[Applause]
stop sending me this [ __ ] it's different
smoking is good for you and other facts
dairy breeders should know what the [ __ ]
specifically
the targeting dairy breeders i think don
draper made that ad
the
guess dairy breeding was big back then
look at this one give your throat a
vacation
smoke a fresh cigarette that's it
there you go
that's nuts
go dude that's so crazy
now that's a face you can trust
that face is saying it's time for school
what the [ __ ] on his forehead a light
what is that
it's like some old school doctor thing i
used to see it all the time i don't know
what is it i don't it concentrates like
light yeah it looks like a reflector
it's probably not a stop magneto
to protect their brains from the
radiation perhaps
it's not nothing like smoking stop
saying that
stop it
so we were going to get into um
stop sending me this [ __ ]
it's nothing like it
and leading hospitals pure refreshment
drink coca-cola delicious and refreshing
is this real stop it
looks real i mean probably a pure drink
of natural flavors with life
sparkle and taste that everybody likes
yes sir that's the ice cold coca-cola
that was one of the pleasant things of
life adding to relaxation and what
relaxation always needs pure stop it
refreshment you're doing ad reads for
coke now
in leading hospitals
so is this real camera did you edit it
uh it's i think it's a real ad i found
you think
i mean did you edit it no i didn't edit
it in many ways yeah it looks real
that's a head mirror that was on the
doctor's head so it creates light yeah
it reflects light when they're doing
some uh different types of examinations
[ __ ] idiots they have a mirror on
their head morons
[ __ ] dumb technology
[ __ ] dumbass seriously so dumb
embarrassing
well let's do embrace masculinity guys i
just can't stop getting bumped on
on [ __ ] tick tock i made one stupid
joke about how
listen i made one joke about how oh well
you spent so much time exercising you
could have just done something with your
life uh and maybe it
i think you said like play video games
or something and people whatever
seriously
it was a joke it was just a stupid joke
an interesting observation i still stand
behind it so not a joke at all well it's
a funny observation it's not that
serious
the observation is that
people spend so much time exercising an
hour a day short to exercise i'm just
gonna be on honest and i'm not so sure
that it's adding an hour per session
onto your life you could just spend that
time doing something else and maybe have
more life
instead of living longer right
it's an interesting theory
it is interesting thank you
well anyway everyone went crazy now now
i'm like embrace masculinity
i didn't say anything about masculinity
just said exercising sucks
so here we go get inspired guys short to
exercise i'm just gonna be honest there
are so many better things to do than
exercise
why is that beta
come on
somebody please
you're still sucking on that [ __ ]
that's good bro dude put this in your
compilation [ __ ]
i'm on a diet balsamic coke you should
do that exercise alexa
nobody cares about that once you think
about it
there's nothing to appreciate a
manslaughter men are not meant to be
prominent men are meant to be submissive
it hurts me to see how corrupt yeah
that's pretty well though
i have never in my whole life heard
somebody seriously express
that like men are useless or should die
or something like
i don't know who exactly you're
responding to
[Music]
men are suffering
this is jordan peterson fans by the way
men they're doing impossible things they
really are
male athletes don't exist anymore
how are we gonna do without men when's
the last time you saw a buff dude
it's been decades
since uh anyone's boxed or lifted
weights yes
i feel like going to the gym is more
popular than ever i feel like everybody
goes to the gym and lifts weights
where would we be without jack the dudes
with our arnold schwarzenegger and his
skittle sized nuts
[Music]
embrace masculinity guys
[Music]
here comes war or army my favorite part
[ __ ] i love that tan just i don't
know bro what's masculine
about a big of a a mega fake tan yeah
he's kind of scary
spaceships what's masking about rockets
you don't think women work in an
astrophysicist they look like a dick and
rocket science
no women working rocket science they're
not smart enough
they're not focused enough women in stem
baby
what women in stem
no women in stem all women it's not for
chicks that's just not for chit shut up
you need to embrace femininity
which means don't work
stay in the kitchen
and
suck me off
sorry
that's what they think though
and then darth vader bro
what is that what is darth vader
that's what he is
darth vader is alpha man when he when he
[ __ ] walked in and killed all those
six-year-olds
masculine that was like man crazy
masculinity dude
dunked his [ __ ] boss down the [ __ ]
death star yeah that was dog that was
bad he [ __ ] dude when he got all of his
limbs cut off and oh yeah peeled off
that was vedas [ __ ] molten lava that
was that was a dick that was metal as
[ __ ] dude he lost it or if he still has
his balls
that's wrong well he does wear the the
[ __ ] cup he does wear like a cup so i
mean his balls may have burned off
i think i'm thinking they would yeah his
voice is super deep though so maybe not
well that's altered yeah oh although
when they take the helmet off his voice
sounds totally different he just sounds
like this yeah yeah he actually
does oh no no actually we've heard him
i forgot there was that one time
he says you mean a return of the jedi
yeah
your sister you're right
[ __ ] nerds up in here
beta behavior go back to darth vader
loser
vader photos with this what's what he'd
be like luke be like what's with all
this feminine energy dad
tell my sister
i just love darth vader
and captain america
dude you're like 12 years old
yeah it's time to grow the [ __ ] up
that's like the icing on the cake
i mean the disturbing part about this is
that it actually has a lot of views and
people love it
make more of those please huge w
this was
too good make more this is hard
it's got me hard
all these men the dogs bodybuilders
life's too short yeah so you got i
always see myself in these like beta
compilations now because i made a stupid
ass joke about
exercise being a wasted time
there's so many better things to do than
ever but this is the fresh and fit fans
so they obviously have an axe to grind
this is jordan peterson fans
you know
1.8 million views let's go
and i'm in the thumbnail
damn
i got to clickbait it
bro be a man i don't give a [ __ ]
be a man
what was that the other day yeah diet
die alone be a man
yeah that guy's good damn loves that guy
i love that guy too
so there you go guys
where would we be without darth vader
force choking people
it's the true idea of masculinity
i dreamed i saw my maternal grandmother
sitting by the bank swimming pool okay
all right jordan
region was exposed dimly
jordan chill bro it had the appearance
of a thick man is this masculine energy
to want to [ __ ] smoking herself
absent-minded this isn't a stop okay she
walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair compacted into something
resembling a large artist's paintbrush
she pushed this at my face i don't know
what this is
several times to deflect her hand
finally unwilling to hurt her or
interfere with her any further i let her
have her way all right all right all
right all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna force choke my [ __ ]
that's masculine energy you've ever
forced chalk someone's [ __ ] before a
dilf
captain america
now there's a real man
you see him getting horny on main the
other day yeah yeah pull that up i did
dude jordan has truly lost his [ __ ]
mind
sorry not beautiful
yeah he found another
cover magazine of a girl he apparently
did find attractive
and the thing is popped out of his
[ __ ] head like the wolf from the
looney tune
dude you're like [ __ ] 70. you've
never seen a a pretty woman before
jesus the smiley face is really what
gets me
i think jordan might be embracing
masculinity right now
it's like dog calling a girl on twitter
very revealing swimsuit
but so the what's funny about this is
the other girl he said sorry not
beautiful about
she was on
sports illustrated correct this is maxim
so it's not even related like
there's a there's a million magazines
with pretty women on the cover like
probably 99 for every 100 that's not
like traditional beautiful woman
and so he's really just dog calling this
girl
[Music]
what the [ __ ] bro
i like my women with big fake titties
and skinny and hot
just like my daughter
she looks like my daughter i love that
and that's that i wonder if her pubes
are long like an artist's paintbrush i i
think i can guess she can wrap it around
my [ __ ] bucco
oh no
[ __ ] you
this woman's named sexiest woman alive i
don't even know who she is
literally never heard of her
you don't know
paige bronnick
have any of you guys ever heard of her
no
no
someone said she's a golfer
i call for instructor
professional
okay social media personality
you could shove a ball up my ass
[Laughter]
yes you could do anything you want to me
ladies yes
you could put the club all the way up
i'll take it i'll be submissive for you
baby
dumbass
men really be tripping these days with
the whole masculine anything
be whatever you want man this doesn't
[ __ ] matter dude
it's the whole point
trans people can be whatever they want
and so can you
the whole you know that whole edit
really shows how gender really is a
social
construction because all the [ __ ]
they're showing could easily be partaken
and by by women and many of them do like
yeah like they show the construction
they show a rocket ship taking off
anyone could do that apparently
masculine things it's just funny because
they're they're kind of undermining
their point it really shows that gender
is a
social construction any better things to
do than exercise
like unless it's like literally
what's one thing that men can do that
women can't get a um
anal orgasm
like a prostate orgasm
that's one thing men can do so unless
they show that
or or or or i guess jerking off with a
penis
yeah but you're pointing to strictly
like biological what the functions i'm
just saying what else yes what else can
a man only do yes so that that would
need to be their embrace masculinity
would be fingering your own [ __ ] and
jerking off
that's all you got and and maybe a
maybe a a
test uh testicle cancer or something can
women use the force
um yes
okay can they horse choke has that been
is that canon
well leia was force sensitive right we
know that did she choke because they
specifically showed darth vader force
choking somebody do we have a canon
example of i'll have to look at women
and jedi yeah
yeah or adventurous i think choke some
people out there you go done oh even in
the new ob launch i knew there would be
yeah yeah yeah yes okay but has a woman
ever caught melanor
uh thor's hammer that captain america
was holding in that clip
oh that's uh
isn't natalie portman in the new one
yeah there you go there you go busted
there you go there you go masky dude
masculinity is crying and [ __ ] right
now toxic masculinity what the hell is
that
the last thing we need is women holding
thor's hammer it's completely
unrealistic
lacks the stre the upper body strength
to wield such a heavy hammer
it's just a [ __ ] joke
not beautiful
remind me that i don't need a man and
men are useless
i love this i love that they're so
triggered by that like that
that one is so obviously she's just
goofing around yeah and he's like i'm
black pill [ __ ] i'm basically ready to
shoot up a school
i'm so i'm so questioning my masculinity
men evolution will soon enough kill you
off
again i don't know the context but i'm
pretty sure just kidding
obviously evolution is not going to kill
you off we need you to reproduce my
friend
not you you won't reproduce but like men
will sure it's better if you don't
and maybe they're not joking in which
case you know what uh there's
some people that are just hateful
and guess what it's probably just a
little taste of your own medicine
because there's been men that [ __ ]
hate women for a long [ __ ] time so i
mean i never met anyone like that in
real life no
that just straight up is like oh my god
they should all die yeah
yeah i mean i don't doubt that those
people exist but you know i never met
one yeah
they just want to be the victim so bad
bro just [ __ ] live your life be
whoever you want man
nobody cares about that think about it
there's nothing to appreciate a man for
men are not meant to be dominant men are
meant to be where did you find these
clips like these are all like super
underground weird [ __ ] i never seen
anywhere ever
it hurts me to see how corrupted you are
[Music]
this is all like men's right [ __ ]
[Music]
yo he's so mad
i have it so [ __ ] tough finally
somebody's speaking for me
dude he's such a man
he's just sitting in front of the
computer screen
life is over
but wait
embrace masculinity
so weightlifting obviously women do that
very successfully
boxing women box right play soccer
actually one of the biggest fighters
of last year was a woman in the mma
rhonda
rousey or whatever yeah
she was one of the high-speed athletes
for that year
i think she switched over to wwe yeah i
know but
just saying but
oh she was ufc's highest paid fighter
yeah yeah for a year there she was she
was the big one
um women can work in construction they
can also play soccer interestingly
more bodybuilding okay dude you
obviously have an issue with
muscles and stuff
i'm pretty sure women fly airplanes
you know
more weightlifting bro you got an issue
okay just say you like the gym you'd
have to make a whole video about it well
their account seems to be a fitness
account at least
you know on the surface
but clear how many women do you see in
the gym bro
i know that you're harassing them and
staring them down your whole time there
okay it's not a masculine thing to go to
the gym and lift weights
dying for your country and
i will give them him that that is a
uniquely masculine thing is uh throwing
your life away on the beaches of some
distant land the truth women in the
military what are you talking about
world war ii
or did they show world war ii yeah
i'm just saying like
they got this one right i mean
uh uh it's i think it was world war ii
though that was a special man experience
i'm not trying to embrace that
masculinity by the way i definitely
don't want to be sent to war to die for
no [ __ ] reason
so
the women can have that one as far as
i'm concerned
[Music]
the rocket ship is the dumbest one that
is absolutely the dumbest one it's just
like a phallic image yeah to insert yeah
[ __ ] exploding
more weight
you know
that that was like a saturn like that's
like apollo program era
i mean have you seen the dudes who
worked at nasa like they're not exactly
exemplars of masculinity [ __ ] i don't
understand that one at all the rocket
ship was so such a bad example more
weight jacked dudes
[Music]
now now he's totally lost the plot darth
vader makes no [ __ ] sense at all
look at these embrace masculinity look
at these paragons of masculinity here i
believe i see a woman back there though
too yeah of course there's women who
worked on
for nasa since the beginning but my
point is that is a bunch of [ __ ]
nerds yeah
what do you guys make of darth vader
being in this i'm actually just trying
to figure it out
power he's just strong is that a male
he's a strong
big drunk guy in the back shoot powers
masculine
big strong man
well he did choke out his wife before
she died
right that's why that's masculine yeah
he didn't take care of his kids
that'd be dead i don't know if that's
i don't think that's exclusively um
captain america michael jordan i mean
what the [ __ ] bro women do all this
stuff
so there you go uh gender is a social
construct they couldn't i could have
done it better myself
uh we did the healthy coke dj
oh [ __ ] what was this one dj academics
who is this guy
that's the guy who had the podcast with
joe budden he said i fell asleep
whenever drake was playing
one of the greatest clips of all time so
is this guy pretty popular
dj academics ian thoughts
yeah yeah he is he's a podcaster or what
what what's his what does he do he's a
streamer and sort of just a general
uh
radio music personality i guess when you
say streamer you mean like he streams on
twitch i don't know he's i think he was
banned at one point i don't know if he's
back on twitch i think so is he popular
there
he does well he is he has a big fan base
i'd say okay interesting
so here is dj academics under fire for a
recent tweet
or i guess it's an old tweet resurfaced
yes where he talks about having
coitus
with a minor which is always you know
the best look you're 31 and being cool
with effing girls that just turned 17
let's hear and see
and to keep it real if you think
uh oh he's setting to keep it real this
is about to go sideways
they keep it real if you think about it
in the bigger scheme of things there's
not much difference between a 20 or a 17
or a 21 and a 17. bro that's a huge
difference 21 and 17 that's four years
that's like a third of their waking life
because you you gain awareness at like
let's say five or four i don't know you
know what i mean
that's a huge difference bro
it's like saying 18 and 14 aren't that
different
right just a couple years
just kind of mean one's a minor and
one's not a minor but i will say listen
i adopted this rule which i think it was
fine i said listen man as long as the
chick got a college id she's getting i
don't care if she's 17 i don't care if
she's 17 and a half i don't care she
just turns 17 that's why she's gonna get
this dick
yo that's almost like he's about to
force it on her too
yo
some people are way too comfortable on
the internet
uh it's gross
you shouldn't really be talking on this
issue james i'm desperate
yeah that doesn't excuse what you did
got a college id she's getting i don't
care if she's 17 i don't care if she's
17 and a half i don't care she just
turned 17. well at least he's checking
their id that's more than james charles
dude right
that is some [ __ ]
so
twitter reaction here we go you know
this is going to be good
there's no point in cancel culture
existing if in cells like dj academics
are still able to have a platform
dj academics getting busted for saying
he'd have sex with a minor
is the least surprising thing i've seen
in a while the man openly sexualized a
15 year old couple years ago is that
right
yeah i think that's what you were
referring hopefully we can finally get
this clown so a lot of people don't like
him are you
i mean yeah i mean a lot of people love
him though too he is pretty popular like
he instead but
he does have a lot of
past controversy oh he's talking about
bad barbie
baby bad baby
bad baby i know it's baby respect so he
said apparently what he tweeted out was
so bad
and then he backtracked it and said he
was hacked and it wasn't him
he was 27 at the time and bad baby was
17.
so he's one of these [ __ ] guys that
was like first in life her only fans i'm
assuming
oh yeah
bad baby got mad titties for a 15 year
old
yo
that's gnarly bro hell no you didn't
tweet that
does that make sister sense that almost
that's almost like uh machine gun kelly
territory yeah very similar yeah
so he he said he was hacked yeah he says
he was hacked
but a lot of people think it's [ __ ]
of course it's [ __ ] did anything
else almost just happen around the time
you know
almost every time somebody's like oh
that wasn't we were gonna act that's
that's
complete [ __ ] bad baby got mad
titties for a 15 year old bro why would
you say that
what the [ __ ]
leave it in the driveway way too
comfortable dude
[ __ ]
oh my god
that's until gnarly kendrick okay so
this is when he falls asleep yeah you're
gonna have to mute the second half of
the video but so he's like a die-hard
drake fan yeah the number one he's
number one drake fan and
he just passed the [ __ ] out during
drake's new album he said he's smoking
on top fives where is he yet
what top five you smoking on kendrick
cause my top five is drink drink drink
drink drink drink
you ain't chill bro
drake doesn't give a [ __ ] about you
doing a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you just talking a whole lot of [ __ ] for
no [ __ ] reason
i just want to know what all these
[ __ ] is talking about is this not the
one that's not
later on yeah it does oh it does okay
yeah i think it's daddy that's a fact
that is cool
so he's streaming i mean he's streaming
the new album yeah and he passed out on
stream and that that doesn't get better
than that
that does not get better
[Laughter]
that is so funny
you can't disrespect kendrick though
give me a break dude come on
oh so how was drake's new album speaking
of drake he dropped the mystery album
did you listen to it ian
yeah i think we all did right i didn't i
haven't heard it i'm not i yeah i heard
them talking about a lot over the
weekend and i listen to it here and my
opinion is a lot different than most of
them so it's called honestly never mind
dan has lots of thoughts i think it's a
dance house album
it stanks
[ __ ] awful well
dan the haters no surprise did anyone
like it i only listened to three songs
from it
and i honestly i thought all three were
fired i'm not gonna lie there you go i
mean i saw most stuff i saw online is
people saying they liked it fair enough
i liked it i liked it there you go
ian
that's some bops
it has some jams
that's pretty good endorsement by ann
did you listen olivia
no i'm pretty adamantly anti-drake
for a reason are you just not your thing
yeah um
i just hate that he did a collab with
chris brown after he broke oh he's so
true so true and shame on all you for
listening yeah [ __ ] all of you guys
that's so true isn't it no and like the
the kid thing but the rihanna thing i
think about what about him trying to
[ __ ] millie bobby brown oh also [ __ ]
he also dated like a 17 year old didn't
he
i guess i don't i'm not familiar with
all the drake lore
no the chris brown thing really gets on
my nerves he's also uh
steak's number one supporter the steak
thing
definitely corny
that's what we were joking about this
weekend too is that um it's kind of like
underproduced the whole album
but uh
we were joking that he made it last
minute to alleviate some gambling yeah
a mistake um cam showcam you look
amazing in that hoodie thank you really
compliments all the colors going on
there
i i try thank you
looking very good very comfortable back
there
really make that nook your own
um well there you have it yeah i haven't
liked
much of drake's output there there is
one
thing that drake did that i really
appreciate though
dan's pulling up some [ __ ] you know
it oh
why is the audio so [ __ ] ripped hold
on hold on let me find the right time
dan's favorite drake moment is
forthcoming
um
this is
this is
everything here it is
oh wait can we show this
wait is this where he gets paralyzed
dude run damn bro you better run in
zigzags this dude didn't learn anything
on the street you gotta run in zigzags
dude not straight lines
it's still so bizarre to me that drake
is like this [ __ ] megastar now
because
in like i don't know early college years
my friends and i would get really
[ __ ] baked and like one o'clock in
the morning and watch degrassi marathon
yeah they [ __ ] laugh our asses off
because why it's bad it's i mean
it's not for me humans yeah isn't it for
like teenage girls i never yeah exactly
i don't know but they would just show
blocks of it like all night long and
we used to watch it all the time and i
remembered drake from that show and
it is still a trip to me that he is now
a superstar yeah
he made it man from that wheelchair all
the way up to the top
you can walk by golly it's a miracle
so i was actually a producer on the new
drake record were you yeah and um drake
and i actually made a song together
um it got leaked somehow but um
he put out a song called falling back
and uh is that right yeah he put out a
song called falling back
they cut the original version we were
going to go with
but somehow this got leaked and it's in
the dock all right i'll play it whatever
this is
this is all royalty free
this is a zac lewis
okay this is original
yeah
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
a little simple there
highly produced
let's get it
[Music]
okay
[Music]
too much flam in my throat okay
[Music]
okay
damn
yo
that was sick bro
why didn't they release that one i don't
know we had creative differences or
something kind of sounded really similar
to some of the other songs too i think
you were saying zach yeah we were
originally going to go with this as the
lead single but i i don't know what the
[ __ ] happened and wow drizzy owns me
that one takes a lot of money yeah that
was kind of dope i like the dichotomy of
like holding my fart and holding my dump
in yeah i i had the idea for the second
song on the record falling back i'm like
what if you just you just mumble over it
and like just grunt and like just have
like one melody you know and he's like
yeah
he stole the idea from me basically so
this is the original demo track which
was supposed to work i'm not even going
to lie that was kind of fire thank you
it is kind of a bob thank you appreciate
it it's a brown noise said love and i
agree it took me five minutes so you
know is that it yeah drake took six but
i think the five minute one's a little
better
so
this is
what is this it was supposed to be the
album yeah this this was the original
freak x zonk yeah
times uh zach lewis
this is we recorded at the wrecker plant
in hollywood
and um i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened
oh men of culture update this is great
yeah
men of culture is a brotherhood of men
who congregate and youtube comments
to enjoy
women performing athletic feats
um
is this embracing masculinity where does
this fit on the spectrum
it's it's empowering they're they're
empowering women in sports oh my god
these videos are crazy yeah with the
introduction of youtube shorts i've seen
the brotherhood has started to grow
again okay notice less so this is the
kind of video you can expect to see and
i'm sorry
it is quite
it is quite shocking i think for some
women to see just how disgusting
men are does it surprise you guys sam or
olivia alina that men
are this
gross or no no no
so but here we'll go to the comments
okay
men of culture we meet again
yes that's so funny though
don't blame algorithm i search this
myself
i find i'm not surprised that men do
this but i'm just amazed by the
community that they built it is very
funny i'll give them that i like the
mini culture thing so are you guys
surprised by this are you grossed out by
it i'm just kind of curious to get a
woman's
take on this men of culture phenomenon
it's like gross and funny okay yeah
i like that
little of both yeah
here is the men of culture
oh god spoops
there's this channel spoops where they
just post videos like that and some of
them have so many views let's go popular
yo no way 35 million views
holy
[ __ ] this is the channel we initially
reacted to when we first found out about
this brotherhood
35 million views guys
is it even anything happening right now
you're muted on your computer okay that
was just the intro
so here we go guys
it's called italian athletics indoor
2019
with pole vault in hd
35 million i didn't know there was such
a passionate
uh fandom for italian pole vaulting
oh yeah but uh
surely this has to be one of the
highest rated oh look you can see where
people looked let's see
let's see where's this bomb
that's funny
these gentlemen are kind enough to
provide time stamps a lot as well
well they don't need to anymore let's
see this is everyone's favorite part
that
doesn't want to watch this poor girl eat
[ __ ]
interesting
are you serious i thought people were
beating off
oh my god she actually got hurt
what the [ __ ]
um
i see
here's another big one
let's see what happens here
oh my god oh my lord jesus i can't
believe this if we go down to the
comments though i put together an album
of comments yeah
wow what a talented cameraman he shot
the whole thing with only one hand
that's foul
how dare you
yeah i'm sorry i told you guys it was
gross
um
whoever made these shorts mandatory is a
genius and a hero
where's all the men of men of culture
the algorithm has reunited us once again
yo dan you missed it but this video has
32 million views
of italian
pole vaulters women
come on
as a distinguished man of culture i
hereby give this phenomenal portrait
athleticism a 10 out of 10. let's see
what is it
yeah
of course
jesus dude
you are men men are men are [ __ ] pigs
man but it is kind of funny i will say
here we have an album of our favorite
comments collected all the men of
culture comments
you guys are going to like these i
promise
oh you did you grab a screenshot as well
to compliment the comments or is this
just the thumbnail let me see
oh that's a thumbnail that's crazy i
think you you clicked a thumbnail
these are just thumbnails i was showing
but yeah this channel is called men of
culture we made again yep that's awesome
this one's straight to the point
this one
10 million views
wait how do i where's the comment you
picked the wrong album there's in the
doc above this link there was another
oh these are thumbnails yeah these are
all thumbnails oh well let's look at
them since we're here yeah look at those
views
[Music]
this is quick oh my god this is crazy
youtube's nuts man you gotta love it
there you have it
let's go to the comments
men of culture we meet again yes my
brothers i thought it was all alone in
the vast space but alas
all my brothers are here
whoever invited those shorts invented
the shorts deserves a nobel prize
men of culture accept my gratitude let's
get together and admire perfection you
let's not gather i don't want to meet
any of these people yeah i mean it's way
better to stay anonymous they stay solo
together we shall empower women in
sports well there you go that's a nice
message of uh uplifting
men of culture we meet again brothers
who won dad we all did son we all did
that's disgusting don't worry with your
son yeah no
very cool
glad to once again be among the ranks of
cultured kings
big thank you to the cameraman around
the world thank you for your service men
of culture salute you
i love the very last one
buenos dias hombres de alta cultura
that's awesome it's spreading the
movement
making it international yeah we're going
global guy but
i will say
if dudes are going to perv out this is
the at least it's like funny usually
it's just gross yeah so i appreciate
that they found a way to make it seem
somewhat funny
you know and not just totally pervy
so we salute our men of culture i guess
right
are there women of culture is there
videos like of dudes
wrestling or something that women can
get i guess no but dude's wrestling it's
the one we just watched empower
masculinity whatever it was i doubt
women watch that the only people that
like super masculine dudes is other
dudes
[Music]
uh what would you guys what would be
something that women might enjoy
that was like inadvertently sexual
maybe wrestling men's wrestling or
something
wrestling
that's not great
i don't see it
on grace
okay let's see if it's there let's do
men putting on gray sweatpants oh great
a grace weapon let's call them
let's see what comes up you never know
compilation that is
uh muscle guys of tick tock grey
sweatpants hold it up sam you asked for
it
i did not you sam let's watch it let's
see what we got here sandwiches back
muscle guys and grace weapon 100 000
views
but if i'm being honest and i hate and i
i i would assume that
well let's take a look where are the
sweatpants
yeah wait go back up damn we didn't see
any [ __ ] yet
i thought we're more concerned with
comments here
well i want to see what the content is
but these these are just thirst traps
they're it's not [ __ ] bait
yeah none of this is really
right it's not like there you go there
he is one
bro
that's awesome
wait hold on dan we're watching this
[ __ ] stop what are you in a hurry what's
the point here we watch so much of the
pole vaulting one okay
does it make you uncomfortable what's
the hurry i just thought the comments
were what we were we'll do both i want
to see what the content is roll down
well don't scroll down yet because i'm
watching this [ __ ] all right enjoy
oh bro
oh so much what are you doing what even
is that move
yeah this is i don't know
[Music]
it's funny
it's actually funny because everything
they're doing is super
embarrassing
i think you guys need to start the
sisterhood all of these dudes sisters of
culture sisters of culture we meet again
sisters of culture
uh james charles kind of ruins sisters
though can we not get some other
suggestions from uh some
people in the chat uh military guys
going through obstacle courses uh that's
fair
chopping wood
chopping wood oh my gosh oh dude
yeah literally yeah
i love the guys on tick tock who speak
very softly in cup i know i've never
seen that oh they're great but i've seen
the wood shopping tick tock i see that
[ __ ] oh we got it it's pretty
interesting type wood wood shopping
there's this one one guy thor that
everyone thirsts over it's like really
uncomfortable
type thor
yeah yeah the top one okay
this is this guy dude you got to go to
tick tock and read the comments they're
[ __ ] vile
it's actually even worse than the mini
culture [ __ ] go to tick tock and look
this guy up
i'm so glad this this came up
now i'm gonna be honest guys i know
everyone's like why is that on your feed
i'm captivated first of all i think wood
chopping is interesting
but also the comments are [ __ ]
the whole phenomenon is insane it's
obviously
a thirst trap it's really not women that
are complaining
that using the larger size is cheating
which i find painfully ironic
but
just to entertain some trolls go back go
back click a high volume or a high
traffic one
he's got some that have a lot of views
he's actually live right now on tick
tock 1.1 million 2.4 million
yeah yeah and one any one of those
come
on oh thank you
what is he gonna spit on the camera
what's that what is the shot i haven't
seen this one
what the [ __ ] is this oh my god that is
so okay go back not this i want the wood
chopping
do that one with guys dude
zach
i don't even want to pick this read the
comments dan go to the top
you weren't even trying to make the
ladies happy in this one you just seemed
seen madison that log
that shirt holding you back sir
great now i'm pregnant
you don't wish my husband came to take
my phone
one thing i don't like about it have you
watched this guy you know who he is
one thing i don't like is he seems like
angry he seems like kind of mean
but i guess that's part of the bad boy
it might be part of the appeal yeah
everybody's saying uh hassan crushing
the yeah i just
i just spent it here's one right here
female equivalent equivalent oh the
watermelon i was talking about a
different one oh god
watermelon crushing is this
maybe
no it's funny i didn't know that the
guy's name was thor so
it's the real life door all right let's
see it
wait and i saw this what's he doing
uh sledge hammering
hammering away
all right listen
i know hassan thurst traps but
he got nothing out thor
what the [ __ ] bro it's like the slowest
sledgehammer what are you in slo-mo
the let's go brandon shirt
you're not gonna hurt anyone with the
speed of that swing
uh the chat seems to
be enjoying it so
to put it lightly oh is that right let
me read the chat you just you degenerate
a lot of
pregnant emojis oh my god women are
disgusting ruling a movie you know what
men why do men get all the creep you
women are just as creepy as men go back
to thor's i'm telling you you've got to
see some of the comments
go back
here send me the link down let me let me
navigate this space it's in the well
here it got buried but here
all right guys let me take over on this
brad on the store chopper okay by the
way i asked sam do you know who this guy
is and she's like yeah
i've seen it i noticed you were a little
hesitant to fess up
[Laughter]
but i get it you know the man chops wood
the real answer is like
jack harlow funniest moments compilation
is that right yeah
that is true i think sam and i both
looked that up
so here's one with six million views
here this is a good one
[Music]
this could be your [ __ ] girl
right now
all right so
get ready for these comments this is way
gnarlier than the pole vaulting single
moms are going crazy right now
oh no what's happening to me
y'all the duets on this video it was
it was the spit for me
bro
[Music]
columbia's
dude went from splitting wood to ripping
it in half pack it up guys we've lost
this one the spitting i mean this has
never been about wood right
[Music]
me next someone said a verified account
jesus
that's what i'm saying men men wouldn't
dare leave comments these pervy i think
you get canceled if men left comments
like me next can you imagine like okay
there's these girls on tick tock that
their strap
doing pottery have you seen those and
they make like foul looking stuff so
imagine if i went to one of those and
said me next
that'd be kind of gnarly
that'd be kind of gnarly right kind of
gnarly i think some men might but not
the men of culture they have a specific
cause men
really yeah they're
every time i watch this it feels illegal
to see it for free i volunteer
um a lot of these comments are for men
ethan no they're all women
bro they're all women the first one you
pointed out his name was anthony anthony
the single moms are going crazy
this is very like facebook mom type sexy
yeah no this is this is mom sexy that
for sure
i'm going to suggest seeing this video
once and then playing it
i are again but with your eyes closed an
ex experience dude that is thirst
strapping like
next level
yeah it's all women dude how dare you
anyway that's that's that so interesting
eh
fascinating
i'm just saying
just saying jessica
oh the wendy show got cancelled we
thought she was coming back but it's
dead
rip
i was i'll be honest i was pretty
saddened by that news that the wendy
williams show isn't coming back because
like as much as you know
she is controversial that show provided
so much entertainment to us
and um
i'm honestly i'm honestly sad that she's
not coming back and i wish her well all
right clap if you think she should
suffer no i'm not going to clap i want
you to do well wendy please clap
no jeb bush
but apparently she's not well right
wendy williams i mean i'm assuming
let's see what's in the newspaper i'm
going back and forth where she's denied
the rumors a few times um oh that's just
weird yeah
she would have come back if she could i
feel like
she didn't want to give that show up
oh here's an article from five hours ago
from new york times
days after her tv show ended william
will wendy williams is already eyeing
her next gig
oh well maybe we'll get her back
she's gonna host a podcast
on apple's itunes okay
there's gonna be some good [ __ ] there
for sure do you think she'll wanna
promote
reach out reach out reach out get her
get her oh my god
can you imagine just playing all your
sound bites to her
i wouldn't even know how to conduct that
interview and it's wild
okay i like that
podcast
it's okay it's okay it's okay yeah
yeah you should be fine
um
there's another
story here about bitcoin getting
absolutely destroyed but
love do you want me to read maybe i'll
skip this for love saying please skip it
too much
too much we've been uh we're over three
hours we could probably wrap it up let's
just check in with bitcoin yeah i mean
it went up a bit
oh that's the stream no yeah it's going
up a little bit so
uh yeah i'm not that sad what do we
think
20 000
yeah it's gone up like probably seven
percent from the bottom
oh i think we're going up alone yeah
we're down to nine ethereum was almost a
900 that was nice
[Music]
yeah carlos is super stoked on that i
had
the the good thing with exactly how much
money i have on in
crypto right now is that it's just the
amount where i'm not really sweating
over it okay that's good i can kind of
honestly just look the other way and
hope for the best that's good
it's but it's right on that edge though
i'm lucky yeah
all right well there you have it a whole
experience today on the h3 podcast
we bring it raw we bring it regola
and this week let's see we'll be back on
wednesday
do we have anything uh special this week
we always have something uh
sam and ian are cooking up a pretty
interesting segment but i i i don't
necessarily want to tease it because
we're not 100 sure it's going to be
ready on wednesday is that right oh on
wednesday we have another interesting
caller our boy
are the the super talented guy who does
the sound the voice
yeah that guy and he does the bird calls
and [ __ ]
that is going to be a huge interview
yeah you did that one
[Music]
that's a quote from him
that too yeah these are all direct
quotes actually
dude he said that and he meant it too
wait did he do that last one too yeah
it's all the same clip
original
you know what i've been doing you guys
um lately i've restarted skyrim
that's right
such a [ __ ] good game what uh what
what's your character what uh i went
pure destruction fire but what uh what
race hell yeah high elf
high elf yeah they're magic boys
what's wrong with high elf i don't know
i just wanted a magic boy
skyrim mmo
no no the actual skyrim skyrim's
it's elder scrolls
skyrim got it got it um yeah aren't the
uh sorry the high elves are like kind of
the the bad guys in that game are they
not
i guess they're dicks yeah not all of
them i'm a great guy i'm a [ __ ] i'm a
good guy the last time i played through
it i was like uh
all stealth pickpocket stealing
degenerate [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
just stealing from everyone everywhere
and here i'm a goody two shoes take your
stupid garbage games somewhere else and
get out of my face what's your problem
with skyrim [ __ ] you tim
just let me have a moment
but you know after playing elden ring
for so long skyrim is they're really
the amount castrated stop
the amount of different ways you can
play skyrim is really incredible yeah
you can you can level
a character in so many crazy different
ways and it's all viable
it's a great game it really is such a
good game one of the best games ever are
you excited for their new game did you
watch any of the star one yeah the you
know i'm not sure i'm not sure star
field i don't know that's what it's
called starfield yeah i see people in
chat saying it okay yeah because like
it seems kind of like
i don't like when they start talking
about there's
tens of thousands of planets to explore
a lot of people did uh yeah i don't like
that that sounds like bad yeah it's all
going to be procedurally generated and
kind of worthless or whatever
i think they did clarify that uh
there'll still be a [ __ ] ton of like
actually crafted content and
the
the other stuff is just bonus basically
the thousands of worlds i don't like
fallout as much as uh elder scrolls
um
i'm a fan of both series and it seems
more like fallout than elder scrolls
well it's you know it's got like the
tech and everything so obviously it
doesn't have the fantasy vibe
but you know what i love about skyrim is
the first person perspective it's so
immersive
i love playing mmo or
rpgs where you see from the first person
you know they you can play it in vr
yeah i'm not doing that that sounds
insane no that sounds like so intense i
want to try that so bad
yeah fallout 3 was fun but
i don't know elder scrolls is better
than fallout i'm sorry to tell you that
guys
uh i'm sorry you know i just am
i'm trying to get back in the elder ring
but it's tough after not playing it so
long and i was so close to the end like
i just feel lost
like i don't know how to wait right
where how far did you get i'm on the
twins the twin boss fight the twins
almost at the end the odd skin god skin
duo
duo yep
so you're literally like three bosses
from the end really keep rocking my [ __ ]
yeah i don't know how to like that's one
of the hardest fights in the game yeah
and if you're just jumping in after
being rusty on that one so wait what's
your what's your build
uh my stats are all over the place
you have this mimic here
you should have to redistribute the as
they're talking about mimicked here's
the best summon in the game oh it's like
a clone i don't think i have that one um
oh isn't it mandatory no that's an
optional one you got to get the mimic
dear bro that shit's insane i should
have consulted you
honestly
yeah mimicked here is like so [ __ ] op
it's insane okay
that'll probably get you there
um i don't know i just love elder ring
it's so immersive and cool and i love
the upgrade path and everything you mean
skyrim but yes skyrim yeah fallout is
just a little too linear for me uh it's
like
you get the super armor you get the guns
you [ __ ] read a gajillion chat
[ __ ] i don't like reading chats
i like both but i i would agree that's
skyrim is the better game for sure yeah
thank you dan
thank you so much you're welcome there's
a lot of gamers in the chat though a lot
of people talking about elden ring
gamers they nerfed mimic tier but it's
still i think it's by far i think it's
still really good but yes it's not as
crazy as it was when we first played the
game right it's still the best part for
you
favorite city in skyrim i don't know i i
don't remember it at all
skyrim or elder rink someone asked
they're so different i i don't think
it's really
one's an action
rpg the other is like an rpg rpg you
know i think they're both
must plays those are both like the best
games ever i mean obviously the combat
in elder ring is a bajillion times
better than elder rings like fighting
kind of sucks it's probably the weakest
part of the game
it's everything else about it that makes
it so impressive no maybe maybe it is
kind of cool though at the same time
just how open it is and like real time
sure
aspects all right like i'm doing the
werewolf quest bro and it's sick bro
people pump dude as a werewolf
it's so fun just running in dungeons and
just slaughtering everybody and eating
their hearts
some people are saying skyrim over eldon
ring i i might actually agree with that
i i might think that eldering might be
the better game
skyrim
but i know they're both amazing
i didn't even play fallout 4 like i
heard it got mixed reviews and i never
even picked it up it's worth playing i
think because people were saying it's
just a clone like it didn't do anything
new yeah that's not entirely true is
that right like the the world was cool
it was a lot it's not as like expansive
as skyrim but it's i would say denser
i especially enjoyed it because it's set
in boston which is a city i've spent a
long time yeah and um
it was fun to see like their version of
boston in the game the uh user scores oh
wow
yeah i think it's still a worthwhile
fallout it's definitely not as good as
skyrim
fallout is such a huge title the way
they just put that out there i feel like
was just not cool like it needs to be
when you put out a new fallout it needs
to be like a paradigm shift it needs to
you know what i'm saying you can't just
rehash the last game it needs to be a
whole new experience like how skyrim was
like a million times better than
oblivion
are you being ironic no no it's
definitely a million times better than
we believe it yeah i mean first of all i
love oblivion but yeah i mean well if
you look at like fallout 2 to fall out
three you know what i'm saying yeah
well they were different uh companies
actually
right the original fallout games were
made by a company that went out of
business and bethesda
bought the property and uh sort of made
it their own that's why those are so
different people are saying they love
fallout though so maybe i'll try fallout
4. yeah played it i mean skyrim is is
alison's like one of her favorite games
of all time she's played at a bajillion
[ __ ] times i can't get her to play
fallout she's like the same way she's
just like ah i don't like it
i like yeah i see that though yeah
did they remaster skyrim or something
like 40 times oh really i was asking if
they remastered oh yeah they've
re-released like 10 i got like the
collector's edition there's two
expansions i don't think i ever played
on skyrim and um
it looks great it plays great
super cool i was just curious it said
release in 2011
originally yeah in 2011 yeah
yeah but if you're looking for a game
i've played new vegas i i like that one
but um
definitely skyrim
oh what about new vegas new vegas is the
best of of those like newer generations
so i played that one and it's not my
favorite game you know what i mean so
maybe i'm just not into that kind of
stuff yeah it gets so repetitive and
fallout because you do like the vac and
you ain't where you do a slow-mo shot
it's like so tedious and so boring and
especially when you get super strong
it's just like
it's just like because you don't really
do real time fighting in that game you
always pause it and do the yeah uh
fallout 4 is the first one where the
like
it actually feels like a modern first
person shooter um it's not as clunky
that sounds more fun to me yeah it
definitely it works uh
a lot better than the earlier ones i
still think new vegas is the better
people love new vegas it's it's a good
one
mostly just for like the story in the
the world in that one
actually new vegas was made by the
original team like i was just saying is
that right
not it's not the same company but like
the same set of people that made the old
school fallouts they came back for that
one which is why a lot of people prefer
that one people are saying cyberpunk and
that's so interesting because we were
all so excited for that game i never
ended up playing and i bought it because
apparently they fixed i mean i played it
for 10 minutes and i said i have no
interest i have no interest in playing
this game yeah that was one of the most
catastrophic
game releases ever yeah for sure that
was a disaster can i just acknowledge
chad said star wars old republic is the
best rpg of all time i agree
i played that it's okay i don't i don't
like i really hate bioware i think their
games suck what the [ __ ] whoa whoa mass
effect
mass effect is is good one and two were
awesome i love those games but for the
most part the games are [ __ ] dumb as
hell
oh man i don't even know it's breaking
maybe in his heart right now yeah that's
the old republic is the [ __ ] like they
made they made one that was like an in a
ninja setting what was that that one
jade empire oh jade empire
we never played that one that game was
[ __ ] awesome i don't know that
dialogue is just so dumb dude but the
world was so cool i did beat that whole
game i did
i just downloaded this effect i'm going
to play the remastered version do you
have you played mass effect before yeah
i played it yeah yeah you would love
that game one and two you beat them both
yeah i read them all
and then the third one was like a
catastrophe right no it's not a
catastrophe it's still a good game they
change that people don't like the ending
which i can't really argue at the end
what's the new one that came out oh
oh
was great and everyone complaining was a
baby okay one two three were awesome
andromeda was the yeah that was that was
the the disaster one year what's with
these developers how do they do this
where they make these awful [ __ ]
games to these legacy classics it's just
so lame uh you know it's
these companies a company is a
collection of people and people move on
and they retire whatever you don't
necessarily have the same people it's
like how the blizzard of today that is
you know completely [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
[ __ ] blizzard they haven't made a
good game in years it's not the same
people that from when we were kids
making good games so wait i saw someone
actually say the name of the bioware
game i was playing it was agony
that was the one oh interesting you
didn't like that one it was it was fun i
played the whole thing i just think the
dialogue is like
i like that one too mind-numbingly
[ __ ] so dumb dude and all the quest
lines are so dumb
i'm sick of pretending like it's not
i thought
look do you remember which one you
played
i played it on a console i think yeah
there was three of them and a lot of
people consider the second one to be a
pretty shitty game
oh so i guess i don't know which one
yeah i played it's possible that you
played uh the bad one so to speak some
people defend it but i don't know i've
heard dragon dogma is good i've never
played it it's like a dark souls like
game yeah i've done that one i haven't
played that one they're remaking the old
republic i'm excited for that
is it a remake or just kind of like a
rematch i think they said remember
remake i'm almost positive yeah
interesting
so um
there you have it
someone said i'm in your walls ethan
they didn't like that
i'm really i'm i went back i'm really
really really enjoying my
second playthrough of skyrim i haven't
played it in a decade it's just so fun
it's a good game i had to play that you
never played skyrim dude it's so
[ __ ] awesome it's such a good game
he's looking for a game so it's got to
be one of the best games ever made right
like easily million percent tops a lot
of lists yeah nice i stopped with good
reason
i stopped playing video games for the
longest time and then i worked here and
you guys ripped me back into this oh
yeah we corrupted you
just when i think i'm out
the thing is if you play skyrim maybe
ask us questions because
it took me a long the learning curve is
kind of crazy because there's a lot of
technical stuff with crafting and
enchanting that's a big part of the game
and it's kind of hard it's not it's
super easy to figure out does not
stop you at all from just doing whatever
the [ __ ] you want which can be kind of
overwhelming because it's a giant
[ __ ] world yeah you're
by no means required to like do anything
at any point you can just kind of wander
off in any direction yeah it's it's nuts
but it's [ __ ] sick dude i would never
be eldering without you guys because it
was so hard for me to get into those
games because they don't explain [ __ ]
but yeah for being in the group chat
with you guys
i don't think you need to worry about
beating elder ring though you got your
enjoyment out of it yeah yeah and you're
like so close to the end that it's you
didn't miss out on but i watched i want
to be elden lord bro
someone said skyrim's easy i kind of do
agree it is oh it's an easy game yeah
all the bethesda games are easy but
that's fine i feel like i don't make it
bad i'm only like level nine and i'm
like [ __ ] roasting people
yeah like i love all the from soft games
but they have a survival mode that's
like insanely hard
they added yeah and i mean you can do
mods and all kinds of stuff
you can make it as hard as you want
i'm gonna try to get lena to play mass
effect because i've explained the story
to her for like past five years
i've been trying to get alley to play
massive mass effect is awesome it really
is a good she just beat the rory which
was the first video game she's ever
played all the way through which is kind
of i don't know it's like one of those i
can't do that yeah
i can't get eel to play any game
i feel like such a swimmer right now i
can't play offline game at all i need
the competitive aspect
you can't play offline games at all
yeah i don't like it i don't like story
based games i want the [ __ ] juice the
adrenaline you know play you know your
kids you never played skyrim
uh no not to any
big extent i have a game i've tried it a
little bit but never stuck with love is
pretty good at online games from what
i've seen
i played way too much online games
growing up i have like 6 000 hours on cs
go for example oh my god
you know i think i might have some crazy
high number too
back back back in the day i played cs go
so much i have
i have a lot an embarrassing amount
well there you have it there it is
there it is folks
we've said it all we've done it all
um
can you do a mods on skyrim on a console
because i'm playing i think maybe you
can actually uh at least to a limited
extent but i um i'm pc gang so i don't
know so you guys think i should mod my
skyrim i mean the mods are incredible
for that game like what kind of mods
they have i know they have like graphics
and stuff but kinds of [ __ ] i mean that
one the one that the last time i played
it which was several years ago now um
i did a mod that completely you know i
was just complaining i think the combat
kind of sucks in that game yeah there's
mods that completely overhaul it to play
much more like a souls game essentially
oh really yeah
it doesn't really change anything else
it just changes the mechanics of how
like swinging your sword feels and
timing and blocking and dodge rolling
and stuff like that dodge rolling an
elder ring that's so crazy they
basically just
made it a souls game and it was fun
wait it's a
you can turn the dragons into macho
man's brandy savage
that's a famous one
or uh
there's a very what the [ __ ] there's a
very infamous one
that seems important you've probably
seen this before but
uh this is a classic
classic skyrim name
oh this is this is
the same one cam sent from a different
angle
yeah this i mean i how you don't really
play the game until you're playing as
macho man randy savage that's crazy what
the [ __ ] yo add some sound i want to see
this
but a hero this is so good the voice to
murder his king and usurp his throne
you started this war plunged skyrim into
chaos and now the empire is going to put
you down and restore the peace
[Music]
was that
it's nothing
carry on
yes general tullius
give them their letters they're saying i
cannot believe you're having fun with
unmodded
skyrim really blessings of the eight
divine
oh
whistleblowers
this isn't the thumbnail i'm only
showing you this so her son knows he was
this close to his first double thumb
wait
he there's only one of it in it i think
he means two days in a row
oh no he's here he's here oh so he is in
the thumbnail bro what the [ __ ]
stop dude yikes
philly's being such a dick
yeah that's the real thumbnail what did
hassan do
disgusting band video the worst yet
how did you justify hassan in this he
probably talked about him for like half
a second he's not even in the title
mr brest is there too are our kinemacies
mr breast
wait why is mr b star arc nemesis
he's suing us remember oh yeah he's
suing him not actually
i by the way
removed everything from the website
thanks consuming mr breast
he's auntie zonka dude
i just sued ethan cline for the third
time
all right guys we'll see you on
wednesday
um have a great week
good night god bless
[Music]
today
[Music]
yeah
let's get it